HEARING --
THIS HEARING IS TITLED IMPROVING
FIRE PREVENTION.
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE HOLDING
IT IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHAIRED BY
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY.
I'M LAURA FRIEDMAN SURE OF
NATURAL RESOURCES AND I WANT TO
WELCOME EVERYBODY WHO'S HERE
TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING IN FOR
PARTICIPATING AND ALSO TO
ANYBODY WHO MIGHT BE WATCHING
THIS ARE LIVE STREAMING IT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SUBJECT --
AS WERE ALL WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
FACING A SERIES OF DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA --
THEY DON'T SIGN SHOW ANY SIGN OF
GETTING.
ANY BETTER ANY TIME SOON IN FACT
THEY SEEM TO BE INCREASING IN
INTENSITY AND FREQUENCY IN
FREQUENCY.
AND WE HAVE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE PAST FEW YEARS AND THAT IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO DISCUSS AND REMINDER
COMMUNITIES ABOUT AND TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE FOCUSING
PARTICULARLY.
ON WHAT WE CAN DO FROM A LOCAL
LEVEL TO HELP INCREASE
PREPAREDNESS RESILIENCY AND ALSO
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES --
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BEING HERE PARTICIPATING --
I'M GOING TO NOW TURN THE
MICROPHONE OVER TO MY CO CHAIR
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR ATTENDING
TODAY I LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN MY CO CHAIR FOR
THIS HEARING --
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
CRITICAL A TOPIC.
I TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAD THE SULFUR FIRE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HD
THE PUNNY FIRE THEM IN THE SCENE --
COMPLEX WHICH INCLUDED BOTH THE
RANCH FIRE AND THE RIVER FIRE.
THESE ARE THE BIGGER FIRES OF MY
DISTRICT SINCE I WAS ELECTED TO
STATE ASSEMBLY OVER TWO YEAR
PERIOD IT'S NO LONGER A MATTER
OF IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A
FIGHTER IS JUST WHEN WILL THE
NEXT ONE OCCUR.
I FULLY BELIEVE THAT WE MUST
REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS IN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES IN OUR
STATE WE MUST STRENGTHEN OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES --
HOMEOWNERS ARE LOCALS AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE FIRE
DOES NOT RESPECT PROPERTY.
LINES I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING WHAT EACH PERSON HAS TO
SAY TODAY --
THERE'S A LOT OF INNOVATION OUT
THERE I AM --
I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING YOUR
TIME FROM YOUR BUSY DAY AS WELL
TO SHARE SOME OF THE NEW IDEAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'LL GET ON WITH OUR
HEARING TODAY.
AND WITH THAT I WANT TO WELCOME
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND TO SEE IF A
SOME MEMORY MRS ANY.
THING HE'D LIKE TO SAY BEFORE WE
BEGIN.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I'M GOING TO
WELCOME OUR FIRST PANEL UP TO
THE DíAS --
MICHAEL RICH WINE IS THE ACTING
STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION --
PROTECTION.
CHIEF OF MIKE RICH ONE WAS
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AS
THE ACTING THAT STATE FIRE
MARSHAL ON DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE BEGAN
AS FIRE SERVICE CAREER THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS AGO AS A FIREFIGHTER
WITH THE HANFORD FIRE DEPARTMENT
HIS SUBSEQUENT YEARS OF SERVICE
INCLUDE THIRTY ONE YEARS WITH
CAL FIRE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL.
DURING CHIEF RICH ONES CAREER
HIS WRITTEN RISEN THROUGH THE
RANKS AND HELD A VARIETY OF FIRE
PREVENTION AND TRADING POSITIONS
WITHIN THE FM.
WELCOME CHIEF TO THE DYESS PROOF
SAITO DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPSE.
BROUGH SAITO LEADS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS TO
WHICH IS THE OLDEST AND LARGEST
CONSERVATION CORPSE IN THE
NATION AND ITS COMMITMENT TO
ENHANCE THE CORPSE MEMBER
VOCATIONAL EXPERIENCE AND EXPAND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FOCUSED PROJECTS.
INCLUDING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
MAKES CALIFORNIA AN EVEN BETTER
PLACE TO LIVE.
WHILE GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
APPOINTED --
BRUCE AS CCC DIRECTOR IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
HIS CAREER WITH THE COURTS GOES
BACK TO NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
DURING THE CCC'S EARLIEST DAYS
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY.
WITHOUT TURN IT OVER TO THE
CHIEF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRS FRIEDMAN IN.
AGUIAR-CURRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YEAH MY NAME IS MIKE RICH WINE
AND I AM THE ACTING STATE FIRE
MARSHAL.
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
OVERGROWN FORCED IN PROLONGED
DROUGHT HAVE RESULTED IN
UNPRECEDENTED TREE MORTALITY IN
THE STATE'S FOREST.
AS WELL AS AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER SIZE AND SEVERITY OF
WILDFIRES.
THE LOSS OF LIFE AND STRUCTURES
AS A DIRECTOR PROXIMATE RESULT
OF WILDFIRES IS AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH.
IN TURN CAL FIRE IS SAID ITS
FOCUS UPON INCREASING THE PACE
AND SCALE OF FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES.
AS A KEY ELEMENT IN OUR BATTLE
AGAINST DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY
WILDFIRES.
WE USE THE STATE'S STRATEGIC
FIRE PLAN AS A ROAD MAP.
THIS PLAN WAS RECENTLY UPDATED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND
WAS ADOPTED BY THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY.
AND IT SPECIFICALLY CALLS OUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF FOR FOR WORK
TO REDUCE THE IMPACT AND
THREADED THESE WILDFIRES HAS
LONG BEEN PART OF OUR MISSION.
BUT OVER THE PAST YEARS WE HAVE
DOUBLED DOWN ON THESE EFFORTS.
IN FACT SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WE HAVE DOUBLED THE NUMBER
OF ACRES TREATED BY FUEL
REDUCTION.
WE HAVE TRIPLED THE NUMBER OF
ACRES THAT HAVE BEEN TREATED BY
PRESCRIBED BURNING AND WE HAVE
INCREASED OUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS BY OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND HOMES.
AND WE HAVE FACILITATED A
HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS. FOR LOCAL
FIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TEN
BUDGET CONTINUES TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN FIRE
PREVENTION.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNATED AS FUEL REDUCTION
CREWS.
THEY'RE DEDICATED TO REMOVING
HAZARDOUS FUELS AND PERFORMING
PRESCRIBED BURNS.
CALIFORNIA'S DRY A MEDITERRANEAN
CLIMATE HAS LENT ITSELF TO
WILDFIRES FOR CENTURIES.
AND WHILE WE MUST TAKE EVERY
STEP TO PREVENT AND SUPPRESS
HUMAN BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
WE MUST ALSO ADAPT TO WILDFIRES.
ADAPTING TO WILDFIRES IS A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH THERE IS NO
ONE SILVER BULLET THAT'S GONNA
SOLVE.
THIS ISSUE.
IT MEANS PLANNING COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HARDENED AGAINST
WILDFIRES WITH FEW BREAKS IN AND
AROUND THE COMMUNITIES.
IT MEANS PROPERTY EVACUATION
ROUTES WATER SUPPLIES FIRE
PROTECTION RESOURCES.
IT INCLUDES BUILDING HOMES OUT
OF AMBER RESISTANT MATERIALS
WHILE MAINTAINING THE ONE
HUNDRED FOOT DEFENSIBLE SPACE BY
REMOVING DEAD AN OVERGROWN
VEGETATION.
IN CALIFORNIA ARGUABLY HAS SOME
OF THE MOST STRINGENT WELL IN
BURNING.
BUILDING CODES IN THE WORLD.
WELL IN BUILDING CODES IN A
WORLD.
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA'S
WHILE AND REQUIRES BUILDING
MATERIALS THAT ARE AMBER
RESISTANT.
OF COURSE THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION IS WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
HOMES THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND THAT IS.
THE BIG ISSUE.
UNDER AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
WHICH WAS CHAIR FRIEDMAN'S BILL
LAST YEAR.
WE ARE IN THE NATIONAL STAGES OF
OUR WORK WITH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND REVIEWING
SUBDIVISIONS AND WILDLAND AREAS.
THAT ARE BUILT WITHOUT SECONDARY
EMERGENCY EGRESS TO IMPROVE.
BOTH PUBLIC EVACUATIONS AND
EMERGENCY ACCESS --
WELL IN URBAN INTERFACE
COMMITTEE IS WORKING TO UPDATE
OUR LIST OF RETROFITS FOR HOMES
THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT STANDARDS.
IN A RECENT CO DEVELOPMENT --
CYCLE WE WE APPROVED.
YOU WILL LIST OTHER STRIPPING
AND SCREENS OVER SKYLIGHTS.
AND THEY WERE ADOPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION WILL BE ADDED TO THAT
LIST OF OF ITEMS THAT HOMEOWNERS
CAN CAN USE TO HARDEN THEIR
HOMES.
AGAINST DICK ENBERG MISSION.
ANOTHER CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
OUR FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
IS OUR LAND USE PLANNING PROGRAM.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
PLANNING BUILDING AND FIRE
OFFICIALS TO ASSIST THEM IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SAFETY
ELEMENTS OF THEIR GENERAL PLANS.
WHEN AND WE PROVIDE THEM WITH
INFORMATION TO ENSURE THEY MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ON THE FIRE
THREAT AND THE RISK IN THEIR
AREA?
WE ALSO SYSTEM WITH LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS AND WORK WITH
THEM TO SPEAK TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE SYNC WITH THE STATE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN.
IN THE CALIFORNIA UNIT FIRE
PLANS.
OR WELL IN FIRE ENGINEERING
PROGRAM COORDINATES ARE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
STATEWIDE THEY GATHER THE DATA
FOR ANALYSIS.
IN THEY ALSO MANAGER DAMAGE
INSPECTION RESPONSE.
THE DATA COLLECTED FROM THESE
INSPECTIONS BOTH BOTH PRE FIRE
IMPOSE FIRE.
HELP US ANALYZE HOW HOME
IGNITIONS OCCUR.
AND WE CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOME HARDENING IN THE FUTURE --
OUR PROGRAM ALSO CLOSELY WORKS
WITH THE CPUC PURSUANT TO AN
ANIMAL YOU THAT WE DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION.
IN OVERALL WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
EFFORTS.
SHARING INFORMATION AND AND DATA.
AND OF COURSE WE BEGIN THE
PROCESS TO REVIEW THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
THAT PROCESS HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN TO DATE WE HAVE
RECEIVED A PLANS.
OUR LOCAL FIRE PREVENTION GRANT
PROGRAM HAS FUNDED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION FIRE
PRETTY PREVENTION PROJECTS
TOTALING.
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE PROJECTS INCLUDE FUEL
REDUCTION PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
WELFARE PLANNING.
FOR THE RECIPIENTS OF THESE
GRANTS INCLUDE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS FIRE DISTRICTS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
FOCUS ON PREVENTING WILDFIRES.
THE CURRENT REVIEW.
OUR CURRENT REVIEW OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY IS --
IS GOING TO GO INTO THE CURRENT
FUNDING WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE MILLION THAT WILL BE
SPLIT BETWEEN FOREST HEALTH
PROJECTS.
AND FIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS.
IN FACT THIS BE NINE A ONE AS
YOU KNOW AUTHORIZED ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS FOR FUEL
REDUCTION AND FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES.
AS WE EXPAND FUEL REDUCTION
TREATMENTS ACROSS THE STATE THEY
WILL UNDOUBTEDLY PLAY AN
INCREASING ROLE DURING FIRE
SUPPRESSION.
HELPING TO SLOW OR STOP THE
ADVANCE OF WILDFIRES ENCROACHING
ON COMMUNITIES.
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER KEY ELEMENT
AND THAT'S THE THE ROLE THE
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS PLAY. 95%
OF ALL WHILE EMPLOYERS ARE
CAUSED BY THE ACTIVITY OF PEOPLE.
THIS MEANS WE ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY NEED RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS TO BE EXTRA CAUTIOUS
OUTDOORS TO PREVENT SPARKING A
NEW WILDFIRE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IS THE LAW.
BUT WE NEED TO EDUCATE ON THE
BENEFITS OF HOME HARD NAME.
IT'S PROVEN TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE CHANCE OF A HOME
SURVIVE IN A WILDFIRE.
OR CAL FIRES READY FOR WILDFIRE
APP IS A GREAT TOOL THAT
HOMEOWNERS CAN USE.
IT IS CHOCK FULL OF INFORMATION
ABOUT LANDSCAPE PROPER
LANDSCAPING ABOUT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTION TIPS.
AND EVEN HAS A LIST OF HOME
HARDENING PROJECTS THAT THEY CAN
AND DO OUR TO MAKE THEIR HOME
MORE FIRE RESILIENT.
AS THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
STRATEGIC FIRE PLAN STATES.
THE VISION IS TO MAKE OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT MORE FIRE
RESILIENT.
MAKER HOMES IN INFRASTRUCTURE
MORE FIRE.
THREATS OF IN MEDICATIONS TO
WILDLAND FIRE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU CHIEF BEFORE WE GO TO
MR SAITO I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THROUGH A THREE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WHO JUST
JOINED US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RICHARD BLOOM
FROM SANTA MONICA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI FROM
TORRANCE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MONIQUE LIMON FROM SANTA BARBARA
WELCOME AND THANK YOU.
WITH THAT MR SAITO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
RICHER FREEMEN THANK YOU MEMBERS.
FOR GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK --
THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRUCE
I TELL I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
AND I OR SORRY.
BOB THERE IS [inaudible]
CURRENT.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS IS --
AS CHAIR FRIEDMAN SAID A FORTY
THREE YEAR OLD.
ORGANIZATION NOW SERVICE BY THAT
FIRST TIME GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
BACK IN THE DAY.
AND OUR MISSION BACK THEN AND
STILL WAS TO PROVIDE --
JOB TRAINING AND SIR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD.
AS THEY ENTER PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENT ARE CUR COMMUNITY
SERVICES ALL THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS HAS TWENTY
FOUR CENTERS ALL THE WAY UP TO
Y. RICA THAT GREEN THERE ARE
HARD HAT THE TOP THERE IS Y.
RICA.
READING FOR THIS NORTH AND THEN --
TO FURTHER SOUTH ON THE NATIONAL
SIT IN SAN DIEGO.
THAT MAKES UP TWENTY FOUR
CENTERS OF THOSE TWENTY FOUR
CENTERS.
EIGHT OR NINE OUR RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS --
FOR BLUE HARD HATS THERE IN THE
MIDDLE AND THEN THE OTHER ARE
NON RESIDENT TO CENTER AND THEN
WE HAVE FOR ENERGY CORES --
ALL OF THOSE NINE RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS --
CURRENTLY THREE HAVE
FIREFIGHTING CAPACITY SO WE HAVE
A BUTTE.
OF FIREFIGHTING CENTER IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE THAT
RUNS THREE CRUISE IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE --
TO FOR WE HAVE TO OF
FIREFIGHTING CREWS OPERATING OUT
OF OUR PLASTER CENTER.
AND NOW WE'RE WORKING UP FROM
TWO TO FOUR CRUZ EVENTUALLY OUT
OF OUR CAMARILLO CENTER
[inaudible]
MMHM MMHM [inaudible]
BURGER.
SO WHAT THE PURPOSE ARE THESE
FOR ME OF THIS DISCUSSION OF
THIS PRESENTATION IS TO PROVIDE
SOME.
SOME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE
CCC IS DONE IN TERMS OF FEEL
REDUCTION.
OF FIRE.
PREVENTION WORKER --
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS OF I
WILL NOTE ARE YOU SHOULD NOTE
THAT FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE THE
NUMBERS ARE MUCH LOWER THAN
THERE ARE FOR THAT WERE FOR THE
PREACHER AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN THE ACCOUNT A LOT
OF ACTIVITY THAT WERE.
THIS JANUARY TWO AT THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR SO WE WILL --
FAR EXCEED THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN NUMBERS --
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND THESE ARE
THE COUNTIES ARE NOT ALL
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
PRETTY SPREAD OUT --
IN SANTA BARBARA --
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MANY
COUNTY THROUGHOUT --
CALIFORNIA --
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN TERMS OF
FIRE PREVENTION AND FOR ONE
PARTICULAR PROJECT THAT WE'RE
VERY VERY PROUD OF OUR SAY THIS
YEAR'S PROJECT CHRISS AMERICORPS
FUNDED PROJECT THAT WORST WE
JUST?
WERE JUST ABOUT TO START A THIRD
YEAR WHERE WE BASICALLY OUT.
FORTY FIVE OUR CORE MEMBERS OR
THREE CREWS WORKING AT THREE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IN THE
EASTERN SIERRA.
WHILE WESTERN SEARS EXCUSE ME --
ONE CREW WORKING OUT A SHAVER
LAKE.
OKAY PRIMARILY WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON.
ANOTHER CREW WORKING IN SEQUOIA
KINGS CANYON AND ANOTHER CREW
ARE WORKING IN TWILA MAE ARM OR
GROSVENOR.
MOST WORKING WITH FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS BUT ALSO OF LOCAL FIRE --
FUELS REDUCTION PROJECT BY THE
CCC WERE AGAIN YOUNG FOLKS ARE
WORKING IN CREWS OF FIFTEEN
WORTH OF SUPERVISION.
AND THERE FELLING TREES LIMóN
UP REMOVING CHIPPING UP OF TREES
OF CHEVROLET BECAUSE YOU KNOW AS
A HIGH. FOR ME THE EPICENTER OF
THOSE HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION DEAD AND DYING TREES AND
SO THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF ERRORS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH.
EITHER THROUGH THIS CASE
AMERICORPS FUNDING OR MORE
RECENTLY OR IN THE PAST WITH OUR
STATE RESPONSIBLE DAIRY FUNDING
OR MORE RECENTLY WITH GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUNNY.
COMING FROM CALIFORNIA.
AND THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
CURRENT PROJECTS --
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
FIRE PROTECTION AGAIN I
MENTIONED WE HAVE SEVEN TYPE ONE
FIREFIGHTING CREWS WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH --
CAL FIRE SO THESE ARE REALLY --
PROTECTION BUT IF THERE EVER
THERE IS A NON SEASON A
FIREFIGHT IN SEASON THEY'RE
DOING MOSTLY FEELS WORK.
IN AROUND THE ERROR IS THAT
THERE ARE ARE COMING FROM IN
THOSE CENTERS ARE OUR CAMERA
PLASTERED BEATS CENTER --
IN THE PROBE IS SOUGHT IN THIS
LIVE IN A PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY WE IDEALLY
WILL INCREASE THE SEVEN TYPE ONE
FIREFIGHTING CREWS.
TO TWELVE BY INCREASING OUR
CRUISE A CAMERA PLASTER AND
BUTTE AS WELL AS OPENING OF OUR
FIREFIGHTING CREWS OUT OUR LOS
PADRES FOR SOUNDS OBISPO CENTER.
OTHER TYPES OF FIRE PROTECTION
AND PREVENTION ACTIVITIES THE
SECOND BULLET THERE ARE.
NOT ONLY ARE WE WORKING WITH CAL
FIRE BUT WE ALSO HAVE PARTNERS
WHO WAS SHIPS WITHIN --
ARE ROLLING OUT TYPE TO
FIREFIGHTING CREWS AND WE HAVE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AT ARE --
TAHOE READING YOU KYRA AND SAN
DIEGO CENTERS.
AND THEN AT THE BOTTOM THE THIRD
BULLET POINT IS ARE WE DO A LOT
OF FIRE PREVENTION.
WORK IN AND AROUND A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY OURS BUT ALSO
FEDERAL AND LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY
OR AS PRIMARILY WITH GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUNDS OR NOW MORE
RECENTLY WITH --
POTENTIALLY WITH PROP SIX STATE
FUNDS AND A ANDIN THE PAST ALSO
OF PROP ONE BOND DOLLARS.
UGH TO OTHER TYPES OF CREWS THAT
WERE RUNNING THIS WHERE ARE YEAR --
ALL AROUND.
REDUCTION AND PREVENTION WORK WE
RUN SOMETHING COUNTY SOMEBODY
TECH CAMP WERE.
A CRUISE OF ABOUT FORTY FIVE
CORPS MEMBERS ARE CRUZ ACTUALLY
TENT SET SET UP TENT IN GROVE
Là INTO WOLLEMI COUNTY.
AND THEY'RE WORKING ON POST
RIMFIRE FEELS REDUCTION AND
HAZARDOUS TREE REMOVAL WORK AND
THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR OF THIS
PROJECT AND WE'RE FIND IT AGAIN
BY GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS AND THEN FINALLY.
WE'RE ABOUT TO SET UP AN ARM
RATE CAPS.
ON A A LOS PINOS TO IN OUR WORLD
WE'RE WHERE WE AGAIN WILL BE
FIGHTING FORTY FIVE COMMERCE TO
WORK EXCLUSIVELY ON FEELS
REDUCTION WORK.
PARTICULAR IN LIGHT OF THE
UNHOLY FIRE THIS PAST --
THIS PAST YEAR SO EVEN THOUGH A
LOT OF NOT.
A LOT OF OUR WORK IS IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF THE THOMAS
FIRE.
AND THE MORE RECENT THE HOLY
FIRE --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
GREAT NEED TO DO THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FUELS REDUCTION FIRE
HAZARD REMOVAL WORK AS WELL.
AND THAT --
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU OUT BEFORE I MOVED TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO WELCOME.
THREE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WHO
HAVE JUST JOINED US ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SUSAN EGGMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUT TASHA BURNER FOURTH
OFF AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
MCCARTY WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR JOINING US IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC --
BEFORE I MOVED TO MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS --
FIRST FOR THE CHIEF AND AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
OF MY FIRST QUESTION IS THAT I
KNOW THE CAL FIRE HAS A GOLD
INSPECTING ALL KNOWN STRUCTURES
IN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA
EVERY THREE YEARS.
BUT IT SEEMS FROM THE DATE OF
THE CALL FIRE IS INSPECTING
ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
STRUCTURES EACH YEAR AND I'M
WONDERING WHAT IT WOULD TAKE FOR
CAL FIRE TO BE ABLE TO MEET ITS
GOAL.
WELL IT'S A GOOD QUESTION --
THIS PAST YEAR WE WE HIT THE THE
HIGHEST NUMBER WE'VE EVER MET
THE GOAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PER YEAR.
IS ROUGHLY A STAB ABLE TO
INSPECT EVERY DAY HOME EVERY
THREE YEARS.
AND SO --
YOU KNOW WE'VE --
THE ANSWER ANY IS IS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING AREAS IN THE
STATE.
AND SO WE WE ARE CONTINUING --
TO TO MAKE STRIDES IN THAT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE IF THE
DATA ARE INSPECTIONS HAVE GROWN
EVERY YEAR THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS HAS RISEN.
EVERY YEAR BUT ARE ARE --
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS REALLY BEEN
UNDER IS UNDER ANALYSIS.
WERE USING SEASONAL WORK RIGHT
NOW SEASONAL OF FOUR STREETS TO
TO DO THAT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTION IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OUR ENGINE COMPANIES WHO WE
RELIED ON GREATLY TO GO OUT AND
AND TO ASSIST WITH THAT BUT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN AS AVAILABLE AS
THEY HAVE.
IN THE IN THE PAST FEW YEARS.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE CONDUCTING A
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS OF WHAT OF
WHAT IS THE WORKLOAD THE TRUE
WORKLOAD AND AND AND AND THE WAY
THAT WE CAN STAFF THAT
APPROPRIATELY.
THANK YOU --
NOW I'M WONDERING ABOUT WHETHER
THERE ARE ANY BARRIERS. TO YOU
AN ACTING FUEL BREAKS NEAR
COMMUNITIES AND HOW IMPORTANT DO
YOU FEEL THAT IS FOR CAL FIRE TO
HAVE A SAY IN THOSE FUEL BREAKS
AND KIND OF HOW HOW IS THAT
GOING GETTING THOSE ESTABLISHED --
WILL FUEL BREAKS.
THE SPAN JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES.
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
OUR UNIT PERSONNEL ARE INVOLVED
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND IN THAT
PLANNING PROCESS.
WE HAVE THE HISTORY THE FIRE
HISTORY.
AND WE AND WE KNOW STRATEGICALLY
WHERE FOR THOSE FEW BREAKS --
WE ALSO WERE CHALLENGED BY THE
PERMITTING PROCESS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LOCAL
PERMITTING.
AND THEN AVAILABILITY OF CREWS
OF OUR PEOPLE KNOWING TO DO THE
WORK BUT ALSO --
TO TO REVIEW THE PLANS.
AND THIS IS THIS NEW NORMAL HAS
IMPACTED FIRE PREVENTION AND IN
THAT KIND OF THE WAY.
CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION I'VE
BEEN ASKING A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN IN FIRE PREVENTION --
REMOVING --
AND DEAD TREES --
CAN BE.
MATIC FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW
INCOME ELDERLY BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE AND LOS ANGELES A COSTS.
ANYWHERE FROM FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS UP I'VE SEEN AS HIGH AS
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HAVE
AN INSURED LICENSED.
TREAT TREAT COMPANY COME IN AND
REMOVE A LARGE TREES SO A LOT OF
PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH THEY KNOW
THEY HAVE A DEAD TREE.
THEY JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THEY
CAN AFFORD IT OR THEIR OF TAKE
THE RISK.
DO YOU KNOW OF ANY PROGRAMS TO
HELP LOW INCOME PEOPLE DO THAT
OUR IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH AND DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUGGESTIONS ON ANY WAY THAT
WE CAN HELP THAT GET DONE DO YOU
WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
IN JURISDICTIONS. TO TRY TO TO
HELP WITH THE UNIFIED AS WELL AS
OUR LAND USE PLANNING AND AND
FIRE PREVENTION PERSONNEL --
THAT'S A TOUGH ISSUE --
IT'S ULTIMATELY THE HOMEOWNERS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE THE
CLEARANCE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME
INSURANCE INCENTIVES FOR THE
LANDOWNER THE HOMEOWNR --
THERE MAY BE SOME GRANTS THROUGH
SOME NON PROFITS THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE BUT THERE THAT'S
ULTIMATELY ABOUT ALL WE CAN WE
CAN PROVIDE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY AND A DIRECTOR SAITO THANKS
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR BLOOM --
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND CAL
FIRE ARE ALLOWED TO DO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WORK IN AREAS
WHERE THE HOMEOWNERS WON'T DO IT --
AREN'T ABLE TO DO IT DO YOU
THINK THE CCC CAN BE HELPFUL AND
AND ANY OF THAT WORK.
I THINK WE CAN AND SHOULD WOULD
TYPICALLY YOU KNOW WERE
PREVENTED FROM ME THE ERROR HAS
TO BE OF BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC
AND TYPICALLY WE WOULD WORK ON
PRIVATE PROPERTIES BUT WE DO
WORK IN AND AROUND PRIVATE
PROPERTIES.
MOST OF TIME TOO FAR SAID
COUNCIL SO THEY'RE HERE TO SO I
THINK THAT'S ONE WAY FOR US TO
WORK ON THOSE PRIVATE PROPERTIES.
AND LET ME JUST ASK YOU IN IF IF
THE CHIEF WANTS TO TO CHIME IN
AS WELL THAT'S FINE THIS IS MY
LAST QUESTION IS FOR MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE
PROBABLY GETTING IMPATIENT DONE
SOME ENERGY EFFICIENCY WORK AND
COULD YOU BE INVOLVED IN HOME
HARDENING.
EFFORTS AGAIN IT'S THE SAME
QUESTION ABOUT IS IT FOR THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS OF TYPICALLY AND
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE NOT WORKED
ON PRIVATE PROPERTY IS LIKE THAT
BUT YOU KNOW I'M AS I'M SITTING
HERE -- WAS
TALKING TO SOME OF MCCARTY
RECENTLY ABOUT A CONSTRUCTION
CORPS MAYBE THERE COULD BE A
HARDENING CORE I NEEDED
DIFFERENT MARKETING --
IMAGER BUT I MEAN ANYTHING'S
POSSIBLE I'M SO THE THOSE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
THEY'VE ALL BEEN ON PUBLIC OR
NON-PROFIT BUILDINGS BUT I I'D
BE INTRIGUED OR INTERESTED TO
SEE IF THERE ARE.
SOME WAY TO DO THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I'LL TURN MY COACH
HERE TO SEE IF SHE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
REGARDING THIS YOU SEE SEE I SAY
THAT OF MANY TREES SO YOU'RE
TAKING DOWN.
AND MANY TREES ARE PROBABLY
CHIPPING SOME.
BUT THERE'S PLENTY OF TREES THAT
CAN'T GO THROUGH A CHIPPER --
WHAT DO YOU WHAT ARE YOU DOING
WITH THOSE TREES ARE THERE IS
SOME KIND OF SOLUTION OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING?
TO GET RID OF SOME OF THAT WASTE.
THERE'S ALWAYS A PLAN BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT THE PONSOR OF A
PROJECT LIKE THAT SO WE'LL WORK
OUT SOME PLAN IN ADVANCE AND SO
YES OF THE CAN'T BE HAULED AWAY.
IF IT CAN'T BE CHIPPED OF A CAT
B. ROW SET UP LOG DACHSHUND
STACKED --
THEY'LL BE SOME KIND OF OPTION
LIKE THAT AND NOT JUST OBVIOUSLY
CUT DOWN THE LEAVES OF THE TREES
ARE TO BRING THEIR ON THEIR OFF
THERE IS ALWAYS SOME PLAN OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO.
AND THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT -- THE
TO DO AS MANY PROBABLY HOMES ARE
CHECKING PROPERTIES --
CAN BE CHALLENGING CONSIDERING
WE'VE HAD FIRES PRETTY MUCH YEAR
ROUND.
AND THE TIMING FOR YOU TO GO OUT
AND ACTUALLY GO OUT AND CHECK
THOSE --
PROPERTIES MUST BE DIFFICULT --
DO YOU HAVE LIKE THIS BUT AS A
SPECIFIC --
TEAM THAT GOES OUT AND JUST
LOOKS AT FIRED.
DEFENSIBLE SPACER HOW'S THAT
WORK WELL IT'S DONE AT THE UNIT
LEVEL -- WE
HAVE TWENTY ONE UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN IN --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS FOUR
STREETS HAVE BEEN APPROPRIATED
IN EACH ONE OF THOSE UNITS --
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT WHETHER PLAYS A
FACTOR IN THAT FIRE ACTIVITY A
TYPICALLY ARE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTORS ARE SEASONAL.
AND THE DEPENDING ON HOW THE THE
PERSONAL MONTHS WERE
APPROPRIATED THEY CAN BE THERE
FOR MONTHS THEY CAN BE THERE
NINE MONTHS --
BUT YOUR ENGINE COMPANIES IN THE
UNITS BUT THERE THE CHALLENGES
THEY'RE FIGHTING FIRE NOWADAYS.
I THINK THE DENTAL HAVE FOR NOW.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER CITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
THE CHIEFS THANK YOU BESIDES SO
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY YOU KNOW I
WANTED TO A TRY TO BRIDGE MY
UNDERSTANDING OF OF CAL FIRE IS
WORK RELATIVE TO THE PC'S WORK
AND IN FIRE PREVENTION AND SO
HOPEFULLY THE THAT THAT DOESN'T
GO.
TOO FAR BEYOND THE THE SCOPE OF
TODAY'S HEARING --
BUT YOU START OFF CHIEF --
YOU YOU TALK ABOUT 95%.
OF THE DO YOU SEE 95% OF ALL --
ARE CAUSED BY PEOPLE
[inaudible]
OKAY -- BUT
ISN'T THE CASE THAT THEY AT
LEAST THE FOR FROM WHAT I RECALL
THAT MOST OF THE MAJOR FIRES.
THAT THE BIGGEST WATER FIRE IS
IN IN IN RECENT YEARS --
MANY IF NOT THE MAJORITY BEEN
CAUSED BY --
THE UTILITY --
PARALYZED --
NO NO.
NO.
SOME OF THE BIGGER FIRES --
ARE STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION OF
COURSE NOW --
BUT ON A DAY TO DAY THAT OF THE
FIRES THAT OUR CREWS ROLL OUT ON
A DAILY BASIS THE MAJORITY THERE
MORE HUMAN CAUSED.
EITHER TRYING TO CLEAR THEIR
PROPERTIES.
HE DUMB HUMAN ACTS --
INTENTIONAL SETS WHATEVER
WHATEVER THE THE BECAUSE IS OKAY --
BAY IS IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME MAJOR
WILDFIRES THAT THAT HAVE BEEN
CAUSED BY THE THE THE VEGETATION --
SOME THE POWER LINES --
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADJUDICATED THIS. ONE
WITH.
WITH SUCH FINDINGS.
IS THAT CORRECT CORRECT OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO SO GIVEN THAT --
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIRE
PREVENTION HERE THAT A BIG PART
OF IT IS.
IS -- THE
THE ELECTRICITY GRID --
YOU KNOW.
AND AND AND AND IT'S INTERACTION
WITH THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
THERE THERE THERE IS A RECENT --
FINDING THAT --
WE DISCUSSED IN THE ENERGY
UTILITIES COMMITTEE HERE AIR --
THE PRESIDENT OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ADMITTED
THAT.
THAT THEY HAD NEVER --
FIND A UTILITY.
FOR FAILING TO TAKE NECESSARY
FIRE PREVENTION --
ACTIVITIES OR OUR EFFORTS --
AND AND AND THAT CONCERNS ME
BECAUSE IT SEEMS THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT STRUCTURES IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS BUT WORK.
TALKING ABOUT THE ELECTRICITY
GRID AND OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MILES OF OF POWER LINES
RUNNING THROUGH SOME OF THE THE
MOST FIRE PRONE AREAS IN OUR
STATE --
DOES THE WAY WHAT IS CAL FIRE IS --
ROLE IN MONITORING THE UTILITIES --
EFFORTS TO ON ON ON FIRE
PREVENTION.
WELL --
BASICALLY OUR OUR ROLE IS THAT
IF WE SEE WHAT WE THINK IS A
VIOLATION WILL REPORT THAT AND
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL OR
PREVENTION PERSONNEL WILL FOLLOW
UP WITH IT.
BUT IT'S ULTIMATELY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE UTILITY TO
ENSURE THAT THE VEGETATION
CLEARANCES ARE MAINTAINED.
AND THE C. P. U.'S GENERAL
SAFETY ORDERS REQUIRE THAT.
THAT THEY ENFORCE THAT AND AND
SO -- AND
AND AND WHO WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY
IS IT TO OVERSEE THE UTILITIES
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ADEQUATELY
AND EFFECTIVELY CONDUCTING --
FIRE SAFETY INSPECTIONS.
I WOULD SAY THAT WOULD BE THE
CPUC ARE.
SO AND AND WHAT --
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE CAL THE
THE CPC IN TERMS OF FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES --
WE HAVE A COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP --
AS I MENTIONED WE ENTERED INTO
AN AMMO YOU ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO --
AND IN THE INTENT OF THAT IMHO
YOU WAS TO INCREASE THOSE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS.
SHARE INFORMATION AS APPROPRIATE --
ON INSPECTION DATA AND AND IT
BOTH ELECTRONIC AND OTHERWISE SO --
AND THEN OF COURSE WITH THE SB
NINE A ONE NOW WITH WELL FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS WERE INVOLVED
IN THAT PROCESS.
BUT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT --
THE THE CPC IS STILL THE LEAD
AGENCY IN TERMS OF AND THE
ENFORCEMENT OF OF WILD FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AS THEY
RELATE TO UTILITIES CORRECT.
THE THE REQUIREMENTS ARE IN THE
P. R. C..
THE CLEARANCE REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT'S THE THE UTILITIES
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE THOSE REQUIREMENTS ARE MET.
AND THE CPU.
YOU SEE HAS SOME OVERSIGHT AND
THE CPC RATHER GENERAL SAFETY
ORDERS DOES CAL FIRE HAVING
OVERSIGHT OVER THE HILL AS
THERE'S NO MANDATE FOR US TO DO
INSPECTIONS --
BUT IT BUT AS I MENTIONED THAT
WHEN OUR CREWS ARE OUT SOME UNIT
TO DO DO --
DO DRIVE THE LINES AND THEY'LL
SITE OF VIOLATIONS --
BUT WHEN OUR CREWS ARE THE
REPORTED THINK IT'S FOLLOWED UP
ON BY OUR FIRE PREVENTION STAFF.
THAT'S CERTAINLY HOW WORKS.
DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION AS TO HOW
GOOD OF A JOB THE CPC IS DOING
IN TERMS OF ENFORCING --
THE WHAT FOR PROTECT THE WHY
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AS
THEY RELATE RELATE TO UTILITIES.
I DIDN'T.
DO YOU HAVE A OPINION AS TO THE
IN THE THE THE THE NATURE AND
THE EXTENT OF THE COOPERATION
BETWEEN.
THE CPC AND CAL FIRE AS THEY
RELATE.
TO WHAT FIRE AND PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES WE HAVE GOOD
COOPERATION YEAH THAT'S
IMPROVING WE HAVE.
WE HAVE DEDICATED STAFF WORKS
VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THEIR
THEIR SAFETY DIVISION.
BUT ULTIMATELY WHEN IT WHEN IT
COMES DOWN.
TO INSPECTING IN ENFORCING THE
WHAT FOR PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
OF THE UTILITIES THAT
RESPONSIBILITY LIES --
LIES WITH THE PC [inaudible]
CORRECT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARTY.
GET THIS TO A QUICK QUESTION
FOLLOWING UP ON YEARS --
SURE FRIEDMAN AS FAR AS THE
CONSERVATION CORPS AND YOU'RE
WORKING YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
DO NOT JUST IN THIS FIELD BUT
ACROSS.
CALIFORNIA AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES AND STEWARDSHIP AND
WORKING WITH.
PEOPLE WHO.
MAY TWENTY SECOND CHANCE AND SO --
HATS OFF FOR THAT --
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW --
ON THE BARRIERS THAT EXISTS OR
HURT RELATED THIS WORKER THAT --
THAT -- THAT
COULD BE STOPPING YOU FROM DOING
MORE -- AS
THAT WORK THAT --
MYSTERY MENTIONED EARLIER AS FAR
AS PATIENTS AND AND RESOURCES OF
COURSE ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO THAT.
ANOTHER'S INITIALLY WERE WORKING
AT THIS YEAR LEGISLATION RELATED
PAROLEES FIRST PROBATIONERS BUT
ANY OTHER POLICIES THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO AND LIGHTNESS ABOUT.
AND I'M MONEY PIECE TO HER I
DON'T THINK POLICIES AS MUCH AS
JUST AN ARDENT ONLY TALKED A LOT
ABOUT BOX SPENDING OUR CREWS
FIREFIGHTING TYPE ON FIRE
FIGHTING CREWS FROM.
SEVEN TO TWELVE THAT'S IN THE
PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET I SEE AS A MEMBER EGGMAN
OR RAISE YOUR HAND WE OFFER AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX WOULD ALSO
INCREASE.
OUT ON FOR NEW OF FORESTRY COR
CRUISE SO FUNDING ISSUES LIKE
THAT ARE WE DON'T HAVE --
UNLIMITED ABILITY TO HIRE JUST A
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
BUT CERTAINLY UP THERE WERE
FUNDING --
AND THERE WERE THERE CERTAIN THE
NEED TO HIRE AND WORK MORE THOSE
YOUNG FOLKS OUR CORE MEMBERS --
SO CERTAINLY FUNDING IS AN ISSUE
AND AND MORE PARTLY THAT I THINK
AND THE REASON I'M HERE SIR.
HOW WE PRIORITIZE THAT PHONE AND
HOW WE DIVVY UP THAT SB NINE A
ONE DOLLARS AND --
RIGHT NOW WE WE HAVE FIVE IN
THIS NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET WE
HAVE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF
SB NINE ONE FUNDING.
OF THAT COULD INCREASE AND ACT
AND BASED ON THESE KINDS OF
DISCUSSIONS I THINK THEY THEY
WOULD GO A LONG WAY. TO MAKING
THAT ARGUMENT IF THERE WAS FOR
WE COULDN'T GET UNLIMITED.
MONEY TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
NEXT YEAR THERE'S LOGISTICS
ISSUES ON YOUR AND AS FAR AS HOW
MANY.
MORE YOU COULD TAKE HOW MANY
MORE INDIVIDUALS YES ECONOMY IS
GREAT IT'S NOT EVERY.
PERSON THAT WANTS TO WORK FOR
MINIMUM WAGE BUT I THINK WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING FOR THAT YOUNG
PERSON I WANT TO CAREER.
AND WANT TO SERVE THEIR STATE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES THAT YOUR
TAGLINE LOW PAY.
CRUMMY WHAT IS IT WAS AGAIN HARD
WORK LOW PAY MISERABLE CONDITION.
HARD WORK LOW PAY BECAUSE THERE
ARE OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BY DECEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER SELLING
MEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU BOTH FOR THE PRESENTATION.
OF PLACE I GOT CAUGHT UP TO
WHERE I JUST WANT TO ECHO WHAT.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY TALKED ABOUT
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE ALL ALWAYS
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT WE DO WITH
ALL THAT TIMBER WHEN WE PULL IT
OUT -- THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE AND USE
MARKETS FOR THAT TIMBER TO BE
ABLE TO GO SOMEWHERE NOT JUST BE
STACKED UP --
CONTINUE TO CONTACT DISEASE AND
THEN SPREADING AS WE KNOW THE AS
WE KNOW IT SPREADS --
SO.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
MY THE BILL I DID LAST YEAR AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX WE START
FOUR NEW BRANCHES WORKING IN
FORESTRY AND ENCOURAGING YOUNG
PEOPLE. TO GET INTO THAT --
HAVE YOU ARE EAST YOU HAVE IDEAS --
AND THEN JUST AS AN ASIDE I DO A
LOT OF WORK AROUND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ALSO AND I KNOW
THAT PEOPLE CAN.
COME INTO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS POST POST
FELONY POST --
WHEN THEY COME OUT OF PRISON?
SO THAT'S JUST ANOTHER ANOTHER
WAY AND I'M THINKING AS WE BEST
USE OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS WE'RE
SUPPORTING AND PEOPLE GETTING
CAREERS ARE ALSO.
AT REDUCING LEVELS OF RECIDIVISM
RATE SO JUST WONDERED ABOUT THE
PLANNING FOR AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SIX AND THEN HOW YOU GO
ABOUT RECRUITMENT. FIVE IN FACT
OUR MEETING THIS THURSDAY WITH
THE ARE GREATER VALLEY CONSERVE
IT LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS TO
BEGIN THAT PLANNING PROCESS EVEN
THOUGH OF COURSE.
THIS BUDGET HAS BEEN APPROVED --
PASSED OUT --
AND I THINK YOU KNOW ALSO --
BEEN PART OF THE TREE MORTALITY
TASK FORCE WITH CAL FIRE.
IN MORE RECENT OF FORCE
MANAGEMENT --
TASK FORCE AND SO ARE MY ROLE IS
NOT AROUND --
BILE MASTER PART OF THE LARGER
PLANNINGPROCESS ONE WERE
REMOVING LOGS THE TREES FROM THE
FORCE AND IF THERE ARE IS A WAY --
TO USE THOSE AS VILE FEELS WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD DO THAT --
AND THEN FOR THE ARE EVER GONNA
CONTINUES DISCUSS I THINK WITH
SUPPORT LIKE FROM --
SOME REMEMBER CARTER'S OFFICE
AND LOOKING AT DIFFERENT WAYS TO
HELP REDUCE RECIDIVISM AS WELL
AS INCLUDE PEOPLE YOUNG FOLKS
THAT NEED THAT SECOND CHANCE OUR
THIRD OR FOURTH CHANCE --
IN THIS PROCESS WE WANT TO BE
VERY ACTIVE AND I THINK IT'S IN
SOME WAYS IT'S SAD --
TYRON ABOUT ARE WE HAVE A NEW ON
A RESIDENTS CITING DELTA WHICH
IS IT ACTING NEXT DOOR TO THE
DJJ INSTITUTION THERE WE HAVE
OUR OTHER CAT REAL RESIDENTIAL
SITE IS NEXT DOOR TO THE OUR
FACILITY AND AND IT'S KIND OF A
RD THAT.
WE HAVE A CONSERVATION CORNER
EVER YOU GET DJ SITE SO WE WANT
TO WORK WITH THOSE.
FOLKS BECAUSE I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE THEY NEED THAT CHANCE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARTY
YEAH I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WHAT
MISS EGGMAN BROUGHT THAT'S A
GREAT POINT IT.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN BE INCARCERATED
BE FIGHTING FIRES OUT THERE AND
THEN WHEN YOU'RE RELEASED YOU
CAN'T COULD DO THE SAME WORK AND
SO I KNOW.
THIS RACE IS WORKING ON THAT BUT
AS FAR AS PROBATION AND PRO WE
WE TREAT DIFFERENTLY AND SO WITH
THE THERE WILL BE A PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR THAT WE CAN ALL WORK
ON CLARIFYING IT FOR PAROLEES
CLEAR FIGHT TWO YEARS AGO.
PROBATIONERS BUT WE NEED TO GO
BACK.
AND AND TACKLE THE ISSUE FOR
PAROLEES TO WORK WITH THE CCC.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER CITY
THANK YOU --
CHIEF BY A IF I MAY HAVE --
BRIEFLY FOLLOW UP ON MY EARLIER
QUESTIONS.
DID DE DO YOU THINK.
THE STATE CAN DO A BETTER JOB IF
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS FAR IF OUR
CAL FIRE WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
UTILITIES --
WILD FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
OR OR OR OR THEIR AND WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE
CHALLENGES OF CAL FIRE TAKING
OVER THE STATEWIDE FIRE
PREVENTION ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
AS THEY RELATE TO THE UTILITIES.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT THAT THAT
WENT OUT OF MY LANE.
I APPRECIATE THE ASK BUT I'M NOT
PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK.
ANYBODY ELSE.
WITHOUT I WANT TO THANK THE
PANEL THANK YOU DIRECTOR THANK
YOU CHIEF VERY VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US. TO HAVE YOU --
COLOR NEXT PANEL UP JANA OF A
LOT TO PICK IS THE COUNTY
DIRECTOR AND FOREST'S ADVISER.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND HUMBLE
AND DEL NORTE COUNTIES SHE'S A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
AND FOR SCIENTISTS TO SCHOOLS IN
INTEREST COVER A WILD.
WIDE SET OF NATURAL RESOURCE
FEEL.
SHE IS CURRENTLY THE CO LEAD OF
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR FIRE
SCIENCE CONSORTIUM.
AS FOUNDING STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBED FIRE
COUNCIL.
SHE ALSO HOLDS AN ADJUNCT
FACULTY OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY FIRES HIS
BEEN LEADING UC'S COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION EDUCATION THE WORK AND
FIRE BUILDING A PERFORMANCE.
NO IN FIRE BUILDING PERFORMANCE.
AT IS KEENLY INTERESTED IN
HELPING COMMUNITIES LEARN TO
BUILD SMARTER.
KATE JARGON HAS BEEN A
FIREFIGHTER FIRE CHIEF AND
FORMER STATE FIRE MARSHAL FOR
CALIFORNIA.
SHE IT HAS RESPONDED TO
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS AROUND
THE STATE AND WORKED ON BOARDS
COMMITTEES COUNCILS AND PASSED
FORCES TO ADVANCE WILDLAND.
URBAN INTERFACE FIRE SAFETY
SHE'S WORKED WITH THE COMMUNITY
PUBLIC AGENCY INDUSTRY AND
POLICY LEVELS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE SERVICE AND IS WIDELY
RECOGNIZED FOR CONSENSUS
BUILDING STYLE AND INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO ALL PROBLEMS.
SHE FOUNDED.
IN TERRA IN TWO THOUSAND TEN A
SUCCESSFUL SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND ANALYTICS OFFER COMPANY FOR
FIREFIGHTERS WELCOME TO BOTH OF
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WITH THAT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IS MEMBERS
STAFF I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DRIVE FROM EUREKA TO
PARTICIPATE IN AN PUBLIC
GOVERNMENT IT'S A IT'S A FUN
PROCESS --
YOU KNOW JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
CORPORATE EXTENSION I I DIDN'T
TALK MUCH ABOUT IT BUT SINCE
THIS IS THE JOINT COMMITTEE WITH --
WITH COUNTY GOVERNMENT JUST
REMEMBER THE COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION IS EMBEDDED IN COUNTY
GOVERNMENT SO I SERVE AS A
DEPARTMENT HEAD WITHIN THE
COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT AND DEL
NORD -- AND
WE ARE IN THIS YOU KNOW NICE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND AND
COUNTY SO --
WERE IN A FIFTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES --
STATEWIDE SO --
WE DO MY JOB IS IN EDUCATION
OUTREACH AND RESEARCH AND MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE WORKED IN
THIS ISSUE OF OF HOME SURVIVAL
IN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT.
WHAT WE CAN DO TO TO BUILD
SMARTER --
TO TODAY'S PRESENTATION IS IS
DESIGNED TO TO TRY AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE PIECES IT'S
GROUNDED IN BOTH THE OBSERVATION
OF OF MANY WILDFIRES AS WELL AS
IN -- MORE
EMPIRICAL LABORATORY BASED STUDY
SO I'VE GOT A FEW SLIDES HERE --
JUST TO ILLUSTRATE SOME OF THE
CONCEPTS BECAUSE I THINK IT'LL
SLIDE SPEAK BETTER THAN THE
WORDS THEMSELVES.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE TAKE
HOME POINTS HERE.
AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO TO START
WITH AND AND THAT IS THAT WE
HAVE A FIRE FIGHTING AGENCY
WHICH AND ANNA FIRE FIGHTING
APPARATUS AND AND I LOVE THE
CONCEPT BUT I'D LIKE TO SORT OF
STEP BACK A LITTLE BIT AND THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT.
IT WITH OTHER NATURAL FORCES
SUCH AS EARTHQUAKES TORNADOES OR
HURRICANES WE DON'T FIGHT THEM.
RIGHT WE ADOPTED WE BUILD
SMARTER AND SO I THINK THERE'S A
A ROOM AND A NEED FOR A SEA
CHANGE IN THINKING ABOUT OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH FIRE.
CALIFORNIA IS YOU KNOW VERY MUCH
OF THE VEGETATION IS FIRE
ADOPTED IN SOME RESPECTS IT'S
ALSO FIRE DEPENDED SO HOW DO WE
GET THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND.
AND HOW DO WE WORK TOGETHER TO
DRY AND ADOPTED BUILD SMARTER --
SIMILAR YOU KNOW TO WHAT WE DO
WITH FOUNDATIONS WITH YOU KNOW
ALL THE ELEMENTS THAT ARE HOMES.
AS DISCUSSED EARLIER THE
MAJORITY OF HOMES ARE LOST FROM
EMBERS IT'LL SHOW YOU SOME
IMAGES OF WHAT THOSE ARE IN A
MINUTE --
BUT THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT FROM A
FLAMING FRONT WHICH MOST PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT WHEN IT COMES THE
FIRE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT NEW
BUILDING CODES ARE HELPING --
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT PERFECT
YET AND WE CAN SEE THAT IN
PARADISE WHERE 25% OF THE HOMES
THAT --
SURVIVE POST TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WILL.
POST TWO THOUSAND A CONSTRUCTION
25% OF THE HOUSES SURVIVED.
OF LET'S NOT OF HIGH THAT WOULD
HAVE LIKE --
TO BUT IF IT DOES SHOW THAT WE
ARE HOW WE ARE CAPABLE OF MAKING
A DIFFERENCE SO HOW DO WE
INCENTIVIZE THE UPGRADES TO THE
EXISTING HOMES AND NOT PROCESS
AND I THINK THAT'S THE OPEN
QUESTION.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO TO LEAVE WITH IS REALLY
THIS IDEA OF WHAT WE THINK ABOUT
WITH PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE.
FORTY TWO NINETY ONE AND WHAT
CAN WE DO AROUND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE -- AND
HOW DO WE GET THE PUBLIC TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF A NON COMBUSTIBLE ZONE
IMMEDIATELY AROUND THEIR HOUSE.
INSTEAD OF THINKING ABOUT
WORKING FROM THE PROPERTY IN
WERE TO THE HOUSE AND HOW DO YOU
WORK FOR THE PROPERTY OUTWARD
AND TAKE CARE OF OUR STUFF RIGHT
IT'S IT'S KIND OF THAT CURTILAGE
THEM WHERE PEOPLE THINK IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OFF LIMITS BUT IN
REALITY IT'S MAKING A MAJOR.
DIFFERENCE IN THE SURVIVAL OF
HOMES LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE IMAGES.
SO I WILL BE ABLE TO TALK IN
EXTENSIVE DETAIL BUT IT'S WANT
TO GIVE YOU THE SENSE THAT.
THE BUILDING CODES ARE DESIGNED
AND A TO THINK ABOUT DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FLAME CONTACT A RADIANT
HEAT OR EMBERS AND THERE ARE
IMPORTANT NUANCES IN EACH OF
THOSE TYPES OF EXPOSURES WITH
YOU HAVE. TOO MUCH HEAT RIGHT
OUTSIDE THE OUTSIDE YOUR
BUILDING LOS CAUSES COMBUSTION
WHETHER OF FLAMES THAT DIRECTLY
TOUCH THE HOUSE OR WHETHER
YOU'RE BEING.
YOU KNOW BOMBARDED WITH THE
HAILSTORM OF LITTLE BITS OF
BURNING EMBERS A AND THAT'S OF A
PICTURE OF THE LAB THAT'S IN --
SOUTH CAROLINA THAT WE'RE SO
MUCH OF THIS IS TESTED JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN ILLUSTRATION OF THE
KIND OF SCALE AND MODELING
THAT'S DONE TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE THESE ISSUES
[inaudible]
SO.
AS A AS WAS SAID EARLIER
WINDBLOWN MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
BUILDING IGNITIONS AND YOU CAN
SEE THIS PICTURE I THINK FOR A
FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE WITH THE
ANGORA FIRE WHERE THERE'S ALMOST.
YOU KNOW VERY LITTLE EVIDENCE OF
FIRE IN THE SURROUNDING --
FORESTED SETTING BUT THE HOME IS
LOST SO HOW DID THAT HAPPEN
RIGHT MOST PEOPLE CAN'T GRASP
THAT THAT YOU THESE NUMBERS ARE
CAPABLE OF MOVING MORE THAN A
MILE IN FRONT OF A FLAMING FRONT.
AND AND CAUSING THESE KINDS OF
LOSSES.
SO THERE YOU KNOW EVERYONE WANTS
TO KNOW WHAT TO DO AND WHERE TO
START AND THAT'S BEYOND WHAT I
HAVE TIME TO TALK ABOUT HERE
TODAY BUT JUST TO SAY THERE ARE
PRIORITIES.
THE SHIFT DEPENDING IF YOU'RE
NEIGHBORING HOUSES VERY CLOSE TO
YOU WHETHER YOU HAVE SOME
SEPARATION BETWEEN BUILDINGS.
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
COURSE IS THE ROOF AND THE ROOF
EDGE -- AND
THEN THE VENTILATION SYSTEM
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
LETTING THAT WARM MOIST AIR OUT
YOUR HOUSE YOUR YOU KNOW SECURE.
WOULD DOESN'T ROT ON THE INSIDE
YOUR HOUSES WITHOUT A CLAIM THE
AWFUL ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO TO BE
STRONG AND BE ABLE TO RESIST OF
THE THE INTRUSION OF EMBERS.
SO YOU NEED YOU NEED SORT OF
LIKE THE GORE TEX OF YOUR HOUSE
IF YOU CAN THINK OF IT THAT WAY.
AND THEN THE VEGETATION
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND BECOMES
KIND OF THIRD AND THAT PRIORITY
LIST -- AND
THEN WE COULD TALK MORE IF WE
HAD MORE TIME THOSE PIECES BUT I
WON'T I WON'T GO INTO THAT NOW.
WELL LET'S JUST THINK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THESE POINTS OF ENTRY
AROUND THE HOME ITSELF SO --
IF YOUR HOME IS --
UNLUCKY TO BE BOMBARDED BY THOSE
EMBERS YOU MIGHT HAVE LOST
BECAUSE YOU HAVE VEGETATION LIKE
LITTLE --
LATER LEAVES ON THE ON THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN IF YOU CAN
SEE NOW I GUESS I GET SHOULD THE
FOR RIGHT HERE WHERE YOU'VE GOT --
THE ROOF TO WALL CONTACT RIGHT
THERE AND THEN YOU CAN SEE THAT
THAT WALL IS NOT RESISTANT TO
THE FLAMES AND AND FIRE CAN
ENTER THAT WAY OR YOUR RAIN
GUTTER CAN CATCH ON FIRE IF YOU
HAVE A LEAVES OR NEEDLES IN
THERE AND THEN.
GET UNDERNEATH YOUR ROOFING.
OR IF YOU'RE ON FORTUNATE TO
HAVE A FENCE AND THE FENCE
ESSENTIALLY CUTS OUT CATCHES ON
FIRE AGAIN FROM THE EMBERS AND
THEN WICKS THE FIRE TO YOUR
HOUSE.
SO THESE ARE THESE ARE COMMON
POINTS OF ENTRY.
THE OTHER POINT OF ENTRY OR
THESE EVENTS WHICH I WAS JUST
TALKING ABOUT AND THIS IS --
FROM INSIDE THE HOUSE AND YOU
CAN SEE THE EMBERS THEMSELVES --
COMING INSIDE THE HOUSE SO
THAT'S A PICTURE SHOWING WHAT
WOULD BE LIKE FROM EITHER GABLE
AND DARRON UNDER EVEN AT THE
DEPEND IF YOU STORE ANYTHING IN
YOUR ATTIC.
OF YOU'RE LIKELY TO HAVE A IN
ACNE IT'S THE HOME PIECE BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT SORT OF WHAT'S
ON ON THE BOOKS AROUND FORTY TWO
NINETY ONE INDEFENSIBLE SPACE --
WE HAVE SORT OF TWO ZONES --
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW FARTHER
AWAY THE REDUCED FEELS OWN FROM
FOR THE PROPERTY LINE TWO OR TWO
HUNDRED FEET --
AND THEN WE HAVE THE SKINNER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ZONE BUT THIS
IS THE KIND OF MATERIAL SO WE'VE
BEEN PRETTY PRODUCING AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT THERE'S THIS NICE
LITTLE --
SET OF FLOWERS OUTSIDE OUTSIDE
THE HOUSE AND THAT GIVES THE
PUBLIC A PERCEPTION THAT IT'S
OKAY TO BE PUTTING VEGETATION
RIGHT CLOSE UP TO THE HOUSE AND
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST NOT NOT
CORRECT --
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE FROM PARADISE --
THIS IS AMBER DAMAGE YOU CAN SEE
THE EMBERS IN THE PALM OF THE
HAND THAT'S LITTLE BITS OF COAL
IT WERE IN THE LAWN --
THIS HOUSE PROBABLY WAS BUILT
AROUND 200-010-2000 --
TWELVE THERE'S A CUSHION THAT
SHOWS KIND OF THE THE LEVEL OF
BURNING THAT HAPPENED AS THOSE
NUMBERS WERE BEING THROWN
AGAINST THAT HOUSE.
MEMBERS CLEARLY CROSSED THIS
LAWN AND YOU'VE GOT BLACK HERE
AND THAT WAS ALL WITH --
COMBUSTIBLE MULCHES AND THEY
WERE PLANTINGS THE HOUSE
SURVIVED BUT EVERYONE OF THOSE
WINDOWS IS CRACKED A AND THE
FIRST PAIN HAS HAS HAS BROKEN --
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE HOUSE
SURVIVED BUT HAD THEY NOT HAD
THIS KIND OF COMBUSTIBLE MULCH
AND VEGETATION PLANTED RIGHT UP
AGAINST THE HOUSE I DON'T THINK
THERE WOULD BE ANY DAMAGE TO THE
HOME.
EL AND HERE'S ANOTHER
ILLUSTRATION FROM THE CAR FIRE
AGAIN IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THIS
HOME WAS ANYWHERE NEAR A FIRE
BUT THE FIRE TORNADO WAS CAME IN
RIGHT BEHIND THIS HOUSE.
AGAIN THE EMBERS WENT OVER THE
LAWN AND HEAR SOME BOX WOULD AND
AGAIN EACH OF THOSE WINDOWS IS
BROKEN AS WELL --
SO IT WOULD BE NICE IF FOR
GUIDANCE AND FOR HAD A MORE
MAINSTREAM UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THIS WHAT THIS AREA IMMEDIATELY
AROUND THE HOUSE.
IS AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS --
FOR HOME HARDENING AS WELL AS
THE FENCE.
SO THE MAIN MUCH METRIC HERE IS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO TEACH
PEOPLE TO WORK FROM THE HOUSE
OUTWARD AND TRYING TO BRING FOR
THIS IDEA OF A NON COMBUSTIBLES
ANSWERED IMMEDIATELY AROUND THE
HOUSE -- TO
PROVIDE GREATER GREATER GUIDANCE
OVERALL --
AND I GUESS WITH THAT.
I THINK ALL CONCLUDES SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU I WILL BE ON YANIS
TEAM ANY DAY [inaudible]
GREAT JOB.
SO THANK YOU CHEERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS --
AND MISTER JARED FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY.
ARE YOU HAVE MY BIO SO I'VE BEEN
INTRODUCED.
AND COULD YOU PULL UP THE POWER
POINT.
SO WHILE OF WHAT HE DOES THAT.
I'D LIKE TO START THE
PRESENTATION WITH THREE POINTS
THAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY PER
THROUGHOUT THE CONVERSATION.
THE FIRST IS THAT HOME HARDENING
IS ONE OF THE MOST FINANCIALLY
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO DEAL WITH WILD
FIRE THREAT.
SO HOME HARDENING IS AT THE
CENTER OF HOW WE MIGHT MAKE
INVESTMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY RELATIVE TO WILD FIRE.
THE SECOND POINT IS THAT DOING
SO IS GOING TO TAKE A TREMENDOUS
LEVEL OF STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
THE THIRD.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
HAZARD VERSUS RISK.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DIFFERENT AND WE
NEED TO MEASURE DIFFERENT THINGS
IN ORDER TO KNOW HOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE.
SO THIS IS WHAT THE PROBLEM
LOOKS LIKE FROM A NUMERICAL
STANDPOINT RELATIVE TO COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY HOME HARDENING AND
WILDFIRES THIS IS HOW THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
LOOKS AT CALIFORNIA.
THEY LOOK AT IT IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS THEY LOOK AT IT DOWN TO THE
HOUSE LEVEL.
BUT THIS IS HOW ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS WE'RE LOOKING AT WHERE THE
PROBLEMS OCCUR THE PERCENTAGES
OF STRUCTURES IN PRIMARILY THOSE
RURAL COUNTIES WHERE THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THINGS ARE
PROBLEMS THE WORST.
THE ANALYSIS UP BY VERA SKI IS
THERE ARE ROUGHLY TWO MILLION
HOMES THAT ARE EXISTING HOUSING
STOCK BUILT PRIOR TO THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT R. IMPACT OF
THE BUILDING CODES.
THAT WE HAVE AS A PROBLEM SETS
SO I LIKE TO THINK OF THINGS
ANALYTICALLY AND I APPROACH THIS
QUESTION ABOUT HOME HARDENING
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF IT TO
TWO MILLION HOUSE PROBLEM HOW
WOULD WE APPROACH THAT.
SO ANOTHER IMPORTANT FACTOR TO
REMEMBER IS WE ARE ON A
HARDENING TIMELINE THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME THAT PEOPLE HAVE
SAT IN FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE
OR COMMISSIONS AND TALKED ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
PIERCY FORTY TWO NINETY ONE WAS
CUED UP.
THAT WAS DONE SO THAT HOUSE
FIRES DID NOT IGNITE FORESTS BUT
NOW ARE USING IT TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM FOREST FIRES.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE POST TUNNEL
FIRE IN OAKLAND WE ENACTED AB A
BASICALLY A BAN ON WOOD ROOFING
IN THE BUILDING CODES AND THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THAT WAS
THE PERIOD WHEN I WAS THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL WE ADOPTED THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
BUILDING CODES.
AND ITS COROLLARY CHAPTER IN THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CODE THROUGH THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
AND THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S
OFFICE SO I WANT TO KIND OF CALL
OUT SOME KUDOS TO THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION FOR BEING A
CENTRAL PART.
OF THIS ISSUE AND THE STATE'S
BUILDING OFFICIALS.
SO.
CONCEPT NUMBER --
ONE POINT NUMBER ONE THAT I
WANTED TO LEAVE YOU WITH A THE
HARDENED HOME.
IT IS BOTH THE BUILDING
MATERIALS AND CONSTRUCTION
TECHNIQUES IT'S THE MATERIALS
AND HOW THEY ARE APPLIED TO THE
STRUCTURE.
AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
BUT YOU MUST MAINTAIN IN ORDER
TO HAVE A HARDEN HOME THE CODES
THEMSELVES PRESUME THAT BOTH ARE
PRESENT AND THE REASON THAT THE
COACH PRESUME THAT IS.
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE YOU HAVE TO BUILD NON
COMBUSTIBLE BUILDINGS AND THE
COST AND CAPABILITY FOR US TO
BUILD THOSE TYPES OF STRUCTURES
OUT THERE.
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE SO
WE SAID THERE MUST BE BOTH
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND BILL
IGNITION RESISTANT BUILDING
MATERIALS FOR THIS TO SUCCEED
AND WE ARE NOT YET SUCCESSFUL IN
ENFORCING BOTH OF THOSE ASPECTS.
THIS IS A A SLIDE FROM A GROUP
THAT'S CURRENTLY AT WORK I'VE
BEEN READING CALLED THE
COMMUNITY PLANNING FOR
ASSISTANCE FOR WILD FIRE --
YOU MIGHT HAVE READ SOME
ARTICLES ABOUT THAT DIFFICULT TO
SEE THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS BUT
AS A AS CHIEF RICH WINE
MENTIONED SYSTEMATIC APPROACHES
WITH A MULTIPLE OF DIFFERENT
MEDICATIONS ARE NECESSARY FOR
THIS.
CERTAINLY LOCAL --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE LAND USE
PLANNING BUT THE THE SUBDIVISION
AND MAP.
DESIGN GUIDELINES GENERAL PLAY.
DO THE GENERAL PLANS EXCEPT A
AND THE FORESTRY LAND MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES UTILITIES WHO ARE --
KIND OF AT OUT THERE IN THE
LARGER FOREST AREAS HAVE A ROLE.
AND THEN THERE ARE THESE
BUILDING AND HARDENED HOMES AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY FEATURES
[inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ONE COMPONENT.
ROBERT I'M GOING TO ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF THOSE FEATURES.
HERE IN A MOMENT.
SO IF YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
SOME KIND OF ACTION PLAN.
AND AND YOU WERE LOOKING AT JUST
WHAT ARE THOSE ELEMENTS THAT
NEED IMPROVING RIGHT NOW. ONE OF
THE CONCEPT IS.
YOU NEED TO HAVE HARDENED
COMMUNITY NEEDS MANY HARDENED
HOMES SO RATHER THAN DOING A FEW
HOMES IN A SCATTERED AREA YOU
NEED TO HAVE A FOCAL POINT.
OF WHAT WAS THE TERM YOU USED A
SATURATION OF HARDENEDHOMES FOR
IT TO WORK IN A COMMUNITY
OTHERWISE.
YOU ARE LIKELY TO BE WASTING
YOUR TIME AND MONEY.
SO YOU MUST PICK AREAS WHERE YOU
CAN DO A LARGE SCALE CONVERSION
OF HARDENED RETROFITTED
STRUCTURES.
ARE IN ORDER FOR THAT TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
THE OTHER IS AN EDUCATIONAL IN
SUPPORT OF OFFICIALS --
YOU HEARD FROM AN EDUCATOR JUST
A MOMENT AGO BUILDING OFFICIALS
FIRE PREVENTION PERSONNEL DO NOT
HAVE YET THE MATERIALS THAT
EDUCATE THEM SPECIFICALLY ON
THESE ISSUES SO I THINK WE NEED
TO ENABLE THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH
WITH CONSISTENT EDUCATIONAL
GUIDELINES PROGRAM MATERIALS.
AND HOW TO GET THAT MESSAGE OUT
THERE AT THE PROFESSIONAL LEVEL
BEFORE THEY TRANSLATED TO THE
HOMEOWNER LEVEL.
INVESTING IN RETROFITTING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT'S THE CORE
OF OUR CONVERSATION TODAY
INVESTING IN RESEARCH CALIFORNIA
SPENDS AN ALARMINGLY LOAN AMOUNT
OF FUNDS IN RESEARCHING THE
MECHANISMS OF IGNITION AND
BUILDINGS.
WE COULD DO BETTER WITH THAT.
WE NEED OPERATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCALS AND
THEN FINALLY WE NEED TO ASSESS
BOTH HAZARD AND RISK.
SO WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT.
WELL THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STATUTES IN AUTHORIZING
PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT A FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES I'M SURE YOU HAVE
ALL SEEN THOSE MAPS.
MANY OF THE LEGISLATION THE
BUILDING CODES MANY THINGS ARE
TIED TO THOSE FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITIES ON MAPS AND AND I
WILL.
CALL OUT CAL FIRE DOES IN AN
INCREDIBLE JOB THOSE ARE WORLD
CLASS ASSESSMENTS OF FIRE HAZARD
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THEY DO.
ABSOLUTELY WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO AND THAT IS IDENTIFY.
THE PROBABILITY AND THE SEVERITY
OF A FIRE OCCURRING IN A CERTAIN
PORTION OF THE LANDSCAPE.
IT TEN THOSE MAPS TELL US WE'RE
THE PROBLEM EXISTS.
THEY DO NOT TELL US WHAT TO DO
ABOUT IT.
THEY DO NOT MEASURE THE
INVESTMENT THAT THEY WILL WE
WILL BE MAKING FOR THAT HAZARD
SO I WANT TO READ JUST A SECTION
AND THIS IS OUT OF THE FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE --
NONTECHNICAL GUIDELINE.
BUT IT SAYS AS REQUIRED BY LAW
THE MODEL THE FIRE HAZARD MODEL.
EVALUATES HAZARD AND NOT RISK
HAZARD REFERS TO PHYSICAL
CONDITIONS THAT CAUSE DAMAGE AND
HAZARDOUS CALCULATED IN OUR
MODEL IS BASED ON THE PHYSICAL
CONDITIONS THAT GIVE A
LIKELIHOOD.
ABOUT WHERE FIRE WILL BURN IN
THE FUTURE WILL PRODUCE WHEN IT
BURNS AND THE PRODUCTION OF THE
AMBER SPREAD AND IT WAS GROUND
CUTTING WORK THAT THEY DID IN
TWO THOUSAND AND MID TWO
THOUSANDS.
IN TERMS OF PREDICTING WHERE
EMBER EXPOSURE WILL OCCUR IN
COMMUNITIES.
IT IS BASED ON THE POTENTIAL
VEGETATION THAT WILL GROW IN THE
AREA OVER THE NEXT THIRTY TO
FIFTY YEARS VERY APPROPRIATE.
RISK ON THE OTHER HAND IS THE
POTENTIAL DAMAGE OF FIRE CAN DO
TO THE VALUES AT RISK IN THAT
AREA UNDER EXISTING AND FUTURE
CONDITIONS.
RISK DOES CONSIDER MODIFICATIONS
THAT AFFECT THE SUSCEPTIBILITY
OF PROPERTY DAMAGE.
RISK INCLUDES DEFENSIBLE SPACE
IRRIGATION SPRINKLERS AND
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION THAT
REDUCE THE RISK OF BURNING
EMBERS IGNITING THE BUILDING.
HAZARD DOES NOT EQUAL RISK BUT
IT IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
DETERMINING RISK.
SO THE REASON I'M MAKING A POINT
ABOUT THIS TODAY IS THE
INSURANCE COMPANY EVALUATES RISK.
WE ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING
HAZARD AND THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
AND I THINK WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD BECAUSE CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS.
A MORE ROBUST CAPABILITY TO DO
THAT TYPE OF EVALUATION CAL FIRE
IS AN EXCELLENT PLACE TO
CONSIDER DOING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LOCAL FIRE SERVICE
EXPERTS THE TECHNOLOGY IS
AVAILABLE THERE ARE MANY THINGS
THAT WEREN'T TEN YEARS AGO.
THAT MIGHT MAKE THAT POSSIBLE
TODAY AND I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
BEEN DOING THIS FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE FROM COLORADO
SPRINGS COLORADO THAT IS THEIR
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE THAT
THEY DO IN A MODELING PROCESS
SIMILAR TO CAL FIRES AND WHAT
THEIR MAP LOOKS LIKE WITHIN
THEIR CITY BOUNDARIES.
SHOULD LOOK VERY FAMILIAR TO US
THOSE ARE THE RED ZONES THAT WE
WORRY ABOUT AND ARE HIGH IN VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD AREAS.
THEY TOOK IT A STEP FURTHER
THOUGH THEY TOOK IT DOWN TO THE
STRUCTURE LEVEL.
AND THEY STARTED TO SAY WELL WE
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
LIVING IN THESE AREAS SO WHAT
CAN WE INVEST IN AS A HOMEOWNER.
AS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS A STATE
OR FOR EDUCATION PARTNER WHAT
CAN WE INVEST IN AND HOW DO WE
MAKE THIS LOOK LIKE WHAT THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY IS DOING TO
ASSESS OUR STRUCTURES.
SO THEY WENT THROUGH A RISK
ASSESSMENT.
SO OVER LATE IN THAT SAME AREA
THOSE ARE THE PARCELS THAT LIES
UNDERNEATH THOSE FIRE HAZARD
JONES.
THEY WENT DOWN AND THEY SAID
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
ABOUT EACH STRUCTURE THAT WE
KNOW ARE IMPORTANT LIKE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
LIGHT BUILDING FEATURES ETCETERA
ETCETERA WHAT IS THE FIRE JUST
DEPARTMENT RESPONSE CAPABILITY
IN THAT AREA AND THEY WENT OUT
AND THEY CREATED AN ABILITY TO
INTERACT WITH THE HOMEOWNER AND
ASSESS THAT IF THE PARCEL LEVEL.
SO FOR FIFTEEN YEARS THEY HAVE
BEEN ON A PATH OF REDUCING RISK.
UNDERNEATH THEIR SEVERE FIRE
HAZARDS.
AND CORRELATING THAT TO THEIR
INSURANCE THEY ALSO HAVE A TAX
MITIGATION OF PROGRAM FOR
REIMBURSEMENT TO HOMEOWNERS TO
HELP INCENTIVIZE THAT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S MY LAST
SLIDE IT IS.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT STARTS
TO ALIGN THE TWO KEY FINANCIAL
ISSUES WHICH IS DISASTER EXPENSE
AND INSURANCE COSTS TRIED IT
START TO ALIGN THEM TOWARD THE
SAME SET OF GOALS.
AND MOREOVER THIS IS A THIS IS
ONE OF THE WAYS BY WHICH YOU CAN
START TO NOW BUILD CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE.
A SINGLE RISK MODEL DEVELOPED BY
THE EXPERTS THAT KNOW HOW TO DO
THAT PARTNERED WITH BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW ARE INVESTMENTS
COLLECTIVELY ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE TEN YEARS FROM NOW WE
CAN LOOK AT A VERY DIFFERENT MAP
OF CALIFORNIA. ONE THAT SHOWS
WHERE WE ARE LIVING IN A MUCH
SAFER WAY.
OTHERWISE WE'LL BE MARRIED TO
JUST A HAS WHERE THE PROBLEM IS
BUT NOT WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO
FIX IT.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU --
THOSE WERE TWO EXTREMELY
INTERESTING PRESENTATION AND
THAT PRESENTATIONS AND I'VE
REALLY BEEN --
VERY HELPFUL TO ME AS I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES --
I HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL AB
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THAT DEALS WITH
THE FIVE FOOT DISPENSED.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
ISSUE IN TRYING TO CLARIFY THAT
AND AND TURN THAT INTO A
REQUIREMENT ON IN OUR FIRE
SEVERITY ZONE SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT --
AND THE TOOLS THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT TO TRY TO HELP.
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS AND
PROPERTY OWNERS WITH HOME
HARDENING.
IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH HIS --
PARTICULARLY IN IN A LOT OF OUR
URBAN AREAS WITH THE HOMES ARE
VERY CLOSE TOGETHER THAT YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO DO
MEANINGFUL LARGE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE --
WORK YOU'VE GOT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN THESE
AREAS ARE MILLIONS OF HOMES IN
THESE AREAS.
SO HOW.
TO TRY TO DEAL WITH THE
HARDENING SIT IN.
WHAT YOU WERE MENTIONING ABOUT
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS IN
COLORADO SO I'M GOING TO ASK
HALF TO SORT OF DRILL DOWN FOR
ME INTO THAT SO THAT I CAN SEE
IF THERE'S ANY --
TOOLS THERE THAT WE HAVEN'T
EXPLORED IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW BRING
ONLINE BECAUSE THAT WAS YOU KNOW
REALLY REALLY INTERESTING TO
HEAR WHAT THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
ON AND I YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN
VERY WORRIED ABOUT.
WHAT HAD WHAT'S HAPPENING IN A
LOT OF THESE AREAS WITH
INSURANCE COMPANIES --
BECAUSE THEY GO BY ZIP CODE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE'RE PEOPLE
MAY HAVE DONE ON THEIR
INDIVIDUAL HOMES AND WHAT THEIR
INDIVIDUAL RISK IS AND THEY
CANCEL WIDE SWATHS OF PEOPLE'S
INSURANCE WHICH IS.
A REALLY NEGATIVE RESULT FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES IN THOSE THOSE
HOMEOWNERS.
SO IF THERE'S ANYBODY HERE FROM
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN THE
ROOM ARE LISTENING I DO HOPE
THAT YOU KNOW.
THE THAT INDUSTRY IS WILLING TO
SIT DOWN AND YOU KNOW WORK WITH
US TO NOT ONLY MITIGATE THEIR
OWN RISK AS UNDERWRITERS WITH TO
HELPBRING POLICIES ONLINE THAT
ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS. TO INVEST
IN THIS WORK WITH THE PROMISE OF
HAVING COVERAGE FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES AT THE END OF IT AND
MAYBE EVEN REDUCE PREMIUMS AT
THE END OF IT --
BUT WITHOUT THAT PIECE I I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS NEVER GOING TO WORK --
FINANCIALLY FOR HOMEOWNERS --
I THESE ARE YOU KNOW THAT IS
WELL IN MENTION THAT WE HAVE TO
MEMBERS WHO HAVE JUST JOINED US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEVON MATHIS OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR
BEING HERE WITH US.
STUFF ONE RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S TOTALLY FINE OTHER OTHER
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS --
THERE ARE --
HOMES THAT CERTAINLY THAT HAVE
ADOPTED A LOT OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS A LOT OF THE
SUGGESTIONS WITH --
HOME HARDENING INDEFENSIBLE
FACING THAT THEY STILL BURNED
DOWN AND WHAT AND FOUGHT WELFARE
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WERE
MISSING THAT'S NOT IN ANY OF
THESE ARE KIND OF WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN THOSE CASES OF THE
FIRE SO EXTREME THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE OR DO
YOU HAVE.
ANYOTHER.
THE IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION THANK
YOU FOR A FIRST ASKING AT I'M
CURIOUS WHAT JAY IS GOING TO
HAVE TO SAY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN PARADISE AND
PARADISE IS ONE OF THE BETTER
ILLUSTRATIONS MOST OF THE HOMES
THAT WERE BUILT IN THE SANTA
ROSA AREA WERE BUILT PRIOR TO
THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
CHANGING CODE SO THERE'S NOT A
LOT TO LEARN FROM HOW THE NEW.
CODE TO PERFORMING THERE THERE
ARE SOME AND IN READING --
AS I SAID OF THE HUNDRED OR SO
HOMES THAT WERE BUILT IN
PARADISE TWENTY FIVE OF THEM
SURVIVED SO.
NOT A GREAT ODD --
BUT THE QUESTION ONE DISCRETE
NEIGHBORHOOD THEY'RE DISPERSED
AND SO -- MY
HUNCH AND WERE WERE TRYING TO
GET INTO THE DATA AND FIGURE
THIS OUT IS THAT THEY PROBABLY
HAD REDUCE SET BACKS AND SAID
THEY WERE INFILL.
MEANING THAT THERE ARE CLOSER
HOMES TO THEM SO THE CONDITION
OF YOUR NEIGHBOR'S HOME CAN
OVERWHELM YOUR HOME IF IT'S NOT
UP TO PAR --
SO YOU CAN YOU CAN HAVE SOME YOU
KNOW AMELIORATING A FAX OF THE
SURROUNDING CONDITION THAT COULD
MAKE A MAKE A DIFFERENCE ON YOUR
OWN HOME SURVIVAL --
YOU KNOW THE THE QUESTION IS YOU
KNOW IS IT ARE THESE RETROFITS
EXPENSIVE ARE THESE BUILDING
CODES EXPENSIVE --
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE STARTING A
NEW CONSTRUCTION IS ABOUT A 5%
ADDITION OTHERS A NEW RESEARCH
REPORT THAT CAME OUT WITH FROM
HEADWATERS ECONOMICS THAT SAID
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE STARTING A
NEW CONSTRUCTION THE MEETING
THESE CODE STANDARDS IS NOT
REALLY A HUGE.
HUGE A BURDEN TO BEAR IF YOU'RE
DEALING WITH RETROFITS WERE YOUR
HOW YOUR ROOF IS IN BAD SHAPE
THAT OF COURSE IT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE --
PROPORTIONATELY BUT IF IT'S YOU
JUST DEALING WITH VENTS AND
OTHER SMALL DETAILS --
THEY'RE NOT OVERLY EXPENSIVE BUT
IN THOSE SITUATIONS YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER YOU'RE GOING
TO BE HAVING DIRECT FLAME
EXPOSURE OR WHETHER GONNA BE
HAVING EMBERS OR SOME
COMBINATION OF THE TWO AND SO%
YOU KNOW.
THERE'S SOME NEW WANTS TO THIS --
AND SO I THINK THAT THE
CHALLENGES TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THOSE HOMES ARE AND HOW
THEY'RE SITUATED IN WHAT THEY'RE
LIKELY TO FOR WHAT KIND OF
EXPOSURE THEY'RE LIKELY TO FACE.
SO AGAIN IF YOUR NEIGHBOR'S HOME
IS IN POOR SHAPE IT'S LIKELY TO
CATCH ON FIRE AND THEN BECAUSE A
LOT OF OF RADIANT HEAT EXPOSURE.
CATCHES ON FIRE NEW ONES.
IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNER WHERE DO YOU FIND.
INFORMATION ABOUT IF YOU HAD.
SO MONEY INVESTED BUT WE'RE THE
BEST PLACE WOULD BE TO INVEST
THAT TO HEART IN YOUR OWN HOME
IS THERE. TO LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS COME OUT AND HELP
PEOPLE WITH THAT IS THERE SOME.
AMAZING WEBSITE THAT TELLS
PEOPLE YOU WANT TO BUY THIS KIND
OF SCREEN FOR THIS KIND OF
SUBJECT HOW WOULD PEOPLE EVEN
BEGIN TO HARD IN THEIR OWN HOMES
OR TO FIND THAT INFORMATION ALL
TO START WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL HAS.
THE POSTINGS AS TO WHAT THE
APPROVED MATERIALS ARE.
THE BEST WEBSITE AT THIS POINT
IS REALLY THE INSURANCE BUSINESS
SUIT FOR BUSINESS AND HOME
SAFETY --
WHICH HAS THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
MATERIALS THERE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WERE PRETTY THIN
STAFFED IN THIS AREA BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO MODIFY A AND BUILD NEW
WEBSITES A NEW MATERIALS TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THAT UP TO SPEED
WE'VE GOT MATERIALS BUT THERE.
BUT THEIR JUST NEEDS MORE WORK
AND INVESTMENT ON IT I DON'T
THERE'S OTHER SOURCES YOU WANT
TO BRING INTO NOT.
SHE MENTIONED THE TWO BEST
SOURCES THAT ARE OUT THERE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE DOES
HAVE MATERIALS THAT ARE I'D.
A GENERAL AND GUIDELINES AND
THEN THE INSTITUTE SAFE ENOUGH
THAT BUSINESS AND HOME SAFETY
ARE HAS --
HOMEOWNER ORIENTED MATERIALS BUT
THOSE ARE NOT WIDELY.
KNOWN WEBSITES --
BUT I DO WANT TO GO BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION --
CHAIR AND AND JUST SPEAK UP FOR
THIS PARTICULAR CONCERN.
AND THAT IS.
I COULD ASK RHETORICALLY IF
ANYONE KNOWS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT ON
RESEARCHING BUILDING IGNITION
LOSS OR BUILDING LOSS IN
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE FIRES.
AND IF ANY OF YOU SAID I DON'T
KNOW I WOULD COME BACK AND SAY
ZERO IS IN TERMS OF WHAT I AM
AWARE OF AS A STATE.
WE HAVE NOT INVESTED AS A LINE
ITEM BUDGET RESEARCH WE HAVE NOT
FUNDED OUR ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
WE DO NOT HAVE A RESEARCH CENTER
IN THIS STATE A CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE FOR THIS ISSUE.
WE DO NOT INVEST A SYSTEMIC
RESEARCH PROGRAM FOR THIS
PARTICULAR HAZARD AND I WOULD.
SUGGEST THAT THAT IT'S TIME WE
DID.
THANK YOU THAT'S A EXCELLENT
POINT.
IN TERMS OF THE THE FIVE FOOT OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE --
AS YOU SAID THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE VERY RELUCTANT TO DOPEOPLE
LOVE THEIR GREEN SPACE PEOPLE
WANT THE COOLING --
QUALITIES OF IT THEY WANT THE
BUTTE AIR QUALITY --
THAT IT BRINGS --
AND YOU KNOW AS I TALKED ABOUT
THE BILL THAT I'M INTRODUCING
YOU KNOW I SAY TO MYSELF YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
OUT AND TELLING PEOPLE TO CUT
THEIR REPEAL GRANDMA'S ROSES
DOWN.
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
ARE THEIR PLANT MATERIALS THAT
CAN BE PLANTED IN THAT FIVE FEET
OR EVEN AGAINST A HOME.
THAT ARE OKAY MEAN A COULD A
SUCCULENT BE OKAY OR IS IT ANY
FOLIAGE IS JUST GOING TO BE BAD
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A SCALE
BUT BUT IT'S AN IT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION --
I TALK ABOUT RIGHT PLANT RIGHT
PLACE -- AND
YOU KNOW REALLY ANY PLANT WILL
BURN UNDER THE RIGHT CONDITIONS --
SO YOU KNOW UNDERSTANDING THE
NATURE OF THE CHARACTERISTIC OF
THE KIND OF PLANT YOU YOU WANT A
PLAN WHERE YOU WANT TO PLANET --
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE A
FRIEND WHO'S A LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTOR WE'RE TRYING TO COME
UP WITH SOME NICE NEW VISUALS TO
HELP ILLUSTRATE THIS SO THAT
IT'S NOT SO --
A DAUNTING YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
IS A MORE THE PLANTINGS ARE YOU
RIGHT NOW THE PLANTE'S GO UP
AGAINST THE HOUSE THE WALKWAY
GOES ON THE OUTSIDE OF THAT WILL
IF YOU SWITCH IT --
YOU CAN YOU CAN ACHIEVE A LOT IN
THAT -- YOU
KNOW IT'S ABOUT MAINTENANCE YOU
KNOW YOU THERE ISN'T A SILVER
BULLET OF A PLANT THAT IS GOING
TO GET YOU THROUGH --
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO TAKE
MAINTENANCE SO WHAT I FIND IS A
PEOPLE ARE RELUCTANT ONCE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES BUT WHEN
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT.
WHAT THESE PLANS MAY BE
CONTRIBUTING TO THAN THAN THEIR
MORE PROTECTIVE OF THEM OVERALL
THANKS MY LAST QUESTION FOR BOTH
OF YOU IS?
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE COURT THE COOPERATION AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STATE AGENCIES
AT THIS POINT IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT WE NEED TO SHORE UP IN
TERMS OF AND TERMS OF THE
COLLABORATION.
SO YES I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
THINGS --
ONE IS -- TO
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE FIRE
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
A FAIRLY UNIFIED GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS AND DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY HAVE LOTS OF WAYS OF
OPERATING TOGETHER YOU'RE
WELCOME TO YOUR WITH MUTUAL AID
CONCEPT--
SO I DO THINK THAT.
ARE MAKING SURE THAT YOUR LOCAL
FIRE AGENCIES ARE AS INVOLVED IN
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING DISCUSSIONS.
ARE AS CAL FIRE IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE OUT REACH
OUT THERE IN THE COMMUNITIES ARM
AND ARE WIDESPREAD IN NEED TO BE
PART OF THAT SOLUTION AS WELL.
AND INCLUDED IN NEED OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL AS EDUCATED
TOGETHER.
OKAY BUT I WILL TURN TO MY CO
CHAIR AND SEE IF HE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS --
I'M JUST GOING TO TALK ABOUT
OBSERVATIONS --
I HAD MANY FIRE ME TOO MANY --
AND MOBILE HOMES --
WHETHER ALSO CALLED MANUFACTURED
HOMES --
THEY WIND UP LIKE TOOTHPICKS.
ENDED MANY RETIRED PEOPLE PEOPLE
ON A LIMITED INCOME LIVE IN
THOSE --
HOMES AS WELL AS FAMILIES AND
OTHER PEOPLE BUT THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOMETHING BECAUSE WHOLE
TRACKS WENT DOWN.
A FEW INTERVIEW COUNTY.
YOU'LL SEE IT.
YOU WENT TO OF SANTA ROSA YOU'VE
SEEN IT --
IT'S HARD TO BE AN INDUSTRY IN
THAT INDUSTRY AND FOR ME TO BE
POINTING FINGERS I'M NOT
POINTING FINGERS I JUST THINK
THAT WE NEED.
TO RE EVALUATE SOME INCENTIVES
FOR SOME PEOPLE TO GET SOME KIND
OF UPGRADES TO THOSE BECAUSE
MANY PEOPLE DO LIVE IN THEM.
AND THERE WERE IN A HOUSING
CRUNCH AND THE LAST THING I WANT
TO DO IS TAKE THAT OPTION OFF
THE TABLE.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE AS
A TEAM HERE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN --
ADDRESS THAT GOING FORWARD SO --
JUST AS AN OBSERVATION THAT WAS
PROBABLY THE MOST OF THE HARDEST
THING THAT I'VE SEEN BECAUSE
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
UNINSURED.
RETIRED.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
I ACTUALLY DO HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION I FORGOT.
DO YOU IS THERE A CONNECTION
THAT YOU SEE BETWEEN.
SORT OF BUILDING DENSITY IN
THESE AREAS AND THE FIRE RISK OR
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IF ONE
HOUSE IS NOT HARD IT'S CLOSE TO
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S MADE FOR IT
LET'S ASSUME THAT THEY'RE ALL.
RELATIVELY NEW HOUSES --
IS THERE A PROBLEM WITH WITH.
WITH THE DENSITY OR IS THE DATA
JUST NOT CLEAR ON THAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING FROM LARGER
DATASETS IS THE PROXIMITY TO
YOUR NEAREST HOUSE IS A HEAVY
CONTRIBUTOR TO TO YOUR SURVIVAL
IN GENERAL IF YOU LOOK AT COFFEE
PARK FOR EXAMPLE MEAN THAT.
THE DRUG PLANS BETWEEN THOSE
HOUSES WITH LESS THAN FIVE FEET
SO YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
EXPOSURE IS IS SIGNIFICANT.
YOU KNOW ONCE YOU'VE GOT ONE
HOME CAUGHT ON FIRE THAT IT'S
IT'S IT'S EASY TO GET
OVERWHELMED.
I MEAN THESE ARE FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGES OF HOW WE HOW WE DEAL
WITH YOU KNOW HIGH DENSITY
LIVING AND SMART LIVING AND I I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT I
I THINK WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT
ARE TRYING TO THINK ABOUT THESE
THINGS IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY AND
I APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION TO THESE
ISSUES.
OKAY.
WHAT ONCE AGAIN ON THE RESEARCH
IS VERY LIMITED IN TERMS OF HOW
WE ANALYZE THIS AND UNDERSTAND
IT -- AND I
WOULD SAY THAT KIND OF
EXPERIENCE LEAVE MY GUESS IS
THAT OUR ANSWERS ARE GOING TO
LIE IN.
IF YOU HAVE CREATED A HARDENED
STRUCTURE AND ENFORCED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THE ANSWER IS
BUILDING DENSITIES ARE
SUPPORTABLE THE HIGHER DENSITIES
ARE ACCEPTABLE.
THAT'S FINE AND THEN AFTER A
WHILE YOU IF THEY ARE
THREATENING TO ONE ANOTHER IF
THEY'RE COUPLE HUNDRED FEET
APART THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
IGNITE ONE ANOTHER.
BUT BUT I KNOW THAT JUST WE KNOW
WHERE WE'RE HEADED WITH OUR
HOUSING NEEDS IN OUR DENSITY
ISSUES -- I
THINK THAT TAKING A LOOK AT HOW
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY IS TREATED --
WILL GO LARGE.
WILL GO A LONG A LONG DISTANCE
TOWARD.
TOWARD ALLOWING THAT WITHOUT
THREATENING ONE ANOTHER.
GOT IT THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS POINT.
SEEING NONE I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE PANEL THAT WAS A REALLY --
VERY VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
I'D LIKE THE BILL WILL COME UP
THE A THIRD --
PANEL TODAY CHERYL AND ROOM I
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT OF GREATER
SAN DIEGO.
J. LOPEZ ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES FIRE DEPARTMENT.
AND CHRISTOPHER THOMPSON BOARD
OF DIRECTORS THE NETWORK NAPA
COMMUNITIES FAR WISE FOUNDATION.
WELCOME.
THE SAYS YOU GET SETTLED WOULD
LIKE TO START MAY START.
CHAU WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST
YES FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY --
AS YOU MENTIONED I'M WITH THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
OF GREATER SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AND I'M ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE FIRE SAFE COUNCIL OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
AND I THINK THAT --
WE HAVE A PERFECT REPRESENTATION
ON HOW LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
INTERFACE WITH FIRE AGENCIES
REGULATORY BODIES.
IN HELPING COMMUNITIES KEEP FIRE
SAFE -- AS A
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
WE WERE SET UP BY AND PICK UP
PUBLIC DIVISION --
RESOURCE.
SORRY DIVISION NINE OTHER
RESOURCE CODES --
WE ARE LOCALLY GOVERNED.
AGENCIES WITH LOCALLY APPOINTED --
ELECTIVE BOARD OF TO WE'RE NON
REGULATORY AS I MENTIONED.
AND WE ARE DESIGNATED AS THE
THIS TOWARDS SUCH SPEAK OF THE
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
NOW IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE NINE
NINETY EIGHT OUR CD'S WITHIN THE
STATE THERE'S ABOUT A FIVE
THOUSAND WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
AND IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
GOT TOGETHER WITH STATE LOCAL
FEDERAL AND TRIBAL FIRE AGENCIES.
TO DEVELOPED.
A FIRE SAFE COUNCIL TO HELP.
COMBAT THE PROBLEM SAID SAN
DIEGO WAS HAVING WITH WILD FIRES --
NOT SURE.
WELL WE CALLED THE THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS WE'VE HELPED TO
ESTABLISH AND DEVELOP THIRTY
EIGHT LOCAL FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE CALL THEM THE NEIGHBOR HOOD
WATCH OF KEEPING SAN DIEGO FIRE
SAFE.
WE OPERATE MOSTLY --
GRANTS CURRENTLY WE ARE RUNNING
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN FIRE GRANTS --
TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND OUR PROGRAMS INCLUDE
CHIPPING.
WHICH IS COMMUNITY CHIPPING ALSO
PRIVATE.
CHIPPING.
OF WHEN CAL FIRE DOES THEIR
MANDATORY DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS OFTEN THEY WILL HAND
OUT OUR OUR CARDS.
AND SAY YOU KNOW CALL THESE
PEOPLE THEY CAN HELP YOU.
AND WE WILL GO OUT THERE AND
HELP THEM MAINTAIN THEIR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WE WILL GET THE
PROPERTIES CLEARED UP.
WE ALSO.
EVERY YEAR DEVELOP --
WE HAVE BI MONTHLY MEETINGS.
IN WHICH OUR EXECUTIVE BOARD WHO
IS COMPRISED OF THE FIRE AGENCY
PARTNERS AN INSURANCE.
AGENCY PARTNER ARE OUR CD AND A
MEMBER AT LARGE.
OF THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE MEETS
BàN KIND OF OVERSEAS AND
WATCHES WHAT THE RCD IS DOING IN
THE MANAGEMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT WE MEET WITH THE LOCAL FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND IT'S A
PHENOMENAL EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERYONE TO GET TOGETHER.
TO EXCHANGE INFORMATION SUIT.
WHAT'S NEW WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES WHAT THEIR ISSUES
ARE HOW THE AGENCIES MIGHT BE
ABLE TO HELP THEM.
AND IT'S BEEN VERY PROACTIVE IN
NOVEMBER WE HAVE SET ASIDE --
WORKSHOPS FOR EIGHTIES OR
COMMUNITIES THAT ALREADY HAVE A
C. W. PPV PLAN COMMUNITY WHILE
FIRE PROTECTION PLAN. TO UPDATE
THEM.
AND THE IT'S IT'S JUST BEEN A
GREAT IN A REACTION.
WE HAVE HAD ALSO SOME.
NEW PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE WORKING ON ALONG WITH
THEIR DEFENSIBLE SPACE WE ALSO
DO OUT REGION EDUCATION.
AND THAT COMES INTO.
CREATING DEFENSIBLE SPACE HOW
YOU CAN DO IT WITHIN YOUR
COMMUNITY --
WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON HOME
HARDENING [inaudible]
ISSUES OF AMBER CHANGING VANCE
OR ONE OF THE BEST THINGS YOU
CAN DO TO HELP PROTECT YOUR
PROPERTY.
SO WE HAVEWORKSHOPS THAT WILL
HELP PROPERTY OWNERS PUT IN
LANDSCAPING.
IN THE PROPER.
AT THE RIGHT PLANT FOR THE RIGHT
PLACE --
WHAT YOU CAN DO TO HELP PROTECT
YOUR HOME [inaudible]
AND THAT HAS BEEN VERY POPULAR
WE ALSO HAVE A CLASS THAT IS
CALLED.
A WILDFIRE BEHAVIOR IN THE
WILLIE.
AND WHAT IT'S LIMITED TO ABOUT
[inaudible]
THIRTY COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS.
BUT IT'S A CAL FIRE PROGRAM THAT
OUR FIRE CHIEF.
TEACHES.
THAT WAS CONDENSED INTO AN EIGHT
HOUR PROGRAM BUT IT WILL REALLY
HELP COMMUNITIES.
LOOK AT HOW.
TO PROTECT THEIR PROPERTIES.
IN CASE OF A WILDFIRE HOW THEY
NEED TO EVACUATE HOW FIRES GOING
TO BEHAVE.
AND THAT IS A VERY POPULAR --
CLASS WITHIN --
ARE -- FIRES
ACCOUNTS THINGS THAT WE'RE NOW
WORKING ON WITH OUR FIRE SAFE
COUNCIL IS THAT --
TO DEVELOP A REGIONAL FIRE PIT.
PROTECTION PLAN WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND SO.
OUR BOARD.
AND THE MEMBERS THAT ARE WORKING
ON THIS WITH THIS.
CONSISTS OF CALIFORNICA SMALL
FOREST.
A US FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE'S
SAN DIEGO COUNTY FIRE THIRTY IN
SAN DIEGO CITY.
SO WE ARE GETTING ALL OF OUR
MAJOR PLAYERS WITHIN THE FIRE
ARENA TO THE TABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER AND EACH.
TO EACH DEPARTMENT SO TO SPEAK
HAS A MAJOR.
AREA OF CONCERN HOW DO WE
COORDINATE THESE INTO ONE
COHESIVE PLAN.
WHERE WE CAN START TACKLING
PROJECTS?
THAT'S ONE OF OUR MAIN --
GOALS THIS COMING YEAR PLUS ALSO
WORKING HARD ON DEVELOPING MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES WITHIN OUR
AREA [inaudible]
OF I THINK I PROBABLY TAKEN
QUITE A BIT OF TIME ALREADY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
WHO WANTS?
TO THE TOPS OF SURE.
SO -- I AM A
A FIREFIGHTER.
BUT I'M GOING TO TALK AS A
HOMEOWNER.
THAT HAS HAD KIND OF A UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE AND KIND OF APPROACH
THIS LOW DIFFERENTLY THAN WHAT
HAS BEEN DONE THUS FAR.
SO -- TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN I MOVED TO
NAPA COUNTY --
HAZARD AREA AND WENT DOWN TO MY
LOCAL FIRE STATION AND SAID.
CAN YOU COME BY AND LOOK AT MY
PROPERTY AND TELL ME HOW I CAN
MAKE IT A SAFER PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
IN A CIVIL BECOME A FIREFIGHTER
YOU CAN FIGURE IT OUT FOR
YOURSELF.
AND THAT'S AN EXAGGERATION --
SO I DID AND I GRADUATED FROM
FIRE ACADEMY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
IN MY VERY FIRST WILDLAND FIRE
WAS ON OCTOBER EIGHTH.
ENOUGH COUNTY FIRES AND IS SO I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IS THE MOST
INCREDIBLE WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE
THAT IT WAS LIFE CHANGING FOR ME --
I I I LOVE BEING A FIREFIGHTER.
WHAT A LOT MORE IS FIGURING OUT
WAYS TO KEEP FIRES FROM
HAPPENING?
SO I LOOKED AROUND MY CHIEF IN
BATTALION CHIEF SAID YOU KNOW
GET ON TO A FIRE WISE --
THAT FIRE SAFE COUNCIL AND I DID.
YOUR PART FIRE SAFE CANCEL MY
START WORKING THROUGH THAT.
IN A MONTH'S TIME WE WAIT REYES
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR FUEL MITIGATION --
AND TALK TO SOME LOCAL
POLITICIANS THEY RECOMMENDED
THAT I GET ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE IN CFF.
I DID THAT AS WELL AND HERE I AM.
AND WHAT I HAVE EXPERIENCED IN
ENCOUNTERED.
IS.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF
THE THINGS BEEN DESCRIBED HERE
ICE I THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS IN PLACE.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE IN PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S VERY
LITTLE ODD CONNECTING UP DOT COM
AND FROM A HOMEOWNER STANDPOINT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT THAT
EXPERIENCE.
BOOTS ON THE GROUND --
THE THE LEVEL OF INTEREST IN
HARDENING HOMES AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT A DEFENSIBLE
SPACES AND WE'VE GONE THROUGH
SLIDES WE TALKED ABOUT IT HERE.
AS A GROUP --
IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR THE
AVERAGE HOMEOWNER.
WHO DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW TO
TAKE THAT PRETTY POSTER THAT
THEY HAVE ON THE REFRIGERATOR
WITH MAGNETS?
AN ACTUAL I IS THAT INFORMATION
TO WHAT DEFENSIBLE SPACES.
AND THE INTEREST IS IS
UNBELIEVABLE I MEAN PEOPLE ARE
REALLY HUNGRY FOR INFORMATION
PEOPLE REALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO MOVE OUT OF THE AREA.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT'S
THE CONVERSATION THAT I HEAR.
THAT GO INTO I'M GOING IN THIS
WEEKEND I'M GOING TO DO A
PRESENTATION. FOR HOW FOR
COMMUNITY OF SEVENTY HOMES.
IN SOMEBODY'S LIVING ROOM POWER
POINT PRESENTATION WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT HOW TO CREATE A FSC.
IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
EVERYBODY'S LIKE YOU KNOW MORE.
AND THEY'RE SCARED.
AND THE NAPA FIRES REALLY
SURPRISED A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT
THEY FIGURE WELL OKAY THE LITTLE
THE LAST FIRE WE HAD IN THIS
YEAR YOU IS THEY HENLEY FIRE I
THINK THAT WAS LIKE SIXTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THE TUBS FIRE WAS ALMOST EXACTLY
THE SAME PATTERN.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THE PARADISE
FIRE THAT REALLY REALIZE THIS IS
THIS IS SERIOUS THIS IS THIS IS
REAL THIS IS ACCIDENTAL.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIND.
WAYS -- TO
MAY HELP THE AVERAGE HOMEOWNER
AND ENDS THE THE THE MARSHALL.
SAID THAT IN 85% OF THE 95% OF
THE FIRES THAT START --
STARTED --
BY.
PEOPLE.
THAT'S TRUE.
AND BIG BIG BEEN --
FIRES THAT MAKE THE HEADLINE
NEWS THAT ASIDE AS A FIREFIGHTER
WHEN WE ROLL INTO A VEGETATION
FIRE IT'S BECAUSE SOMEONE WITH
CUTTING THE GRASS AND AND THE
BLADE SPARKED IN SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THESE
HUGE CATASTROPHIC FIRES AGAIN
JUST BE THE VET FIRES THAT WE
SEE IN AND OUT.
DAY IN DAY OUT [inaudible]
THE THE PROBLEM THOUGH IS THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW.
TO ACTUALIZE THE INFORMATION
THAT IS READILY AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
AND THAT FIRE SAFE COUNCILS ARE
A WONDERFUL WONDERFUL WAY TO DO
THAT WE CREATE A COMMUNITY --
WE PULL PEOPLE IN WE GET A HOLD
OF THEIR NAMES THEIR EMAILS OR
PHONE NUMBERS.
WE WE WE WERE HAVING --
ONE IN MY COMMUNITY AND IN RIGHT
BEFORE FIRE SEASON STARTS AND
WE'RE GOING THAT HAVE THE FIRE
MARSHAL COLM MEMBER GOING TO
HAVE THAT FIRE CHIEF COME IN THE
BATTALION CHIEF FOR CAN HAVE
THEIR SHARE OF MAY I GO INTO
THESE PEOPLE'S HOMES AND I SAID
ARE YOU REALLY.
DO YOU REALIZE.
THAT THERE IS NOW A EVACUATION
HIGH LOW SIREN THAT THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WILL
UTILIZE IN WHEN YOU HEAR IT.
YOU GET OUT OF DODGE AND
EVERYTHING NINE NEVER.
THAT'S SCARY.
N. SO --
IT'S IT HAPPENS.
OKAY.
SO WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN FIX THAT
BY A BY REALLY EMPHASIZING THE
FS SEASON WHAT WE'RE DOING AT
THE NC FF.
BUT IT IT CAN'T BE AS CLUMSY AS
IT IS IN TERMS OF GETTING HOLD
OF MONEY.
AND IT CAN'T BE THE LITTLE
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE SEEING --
COME IN THAT YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE COMING IN TO DO
FILL MITIGATION AND WE WILL SEE
THAT IN THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRE
SEASON.
WE WANT TO HOLD A COMMUNITY
MEETING.
WE WANT TO HAVE THESE PEOPLE
COME IN AND WE'RE TRYING TO
RAISE FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND WE CAN GET THAT --
BUT WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF FUND RAISING AND MAIL
PANCAKE BREAKFASTS AND AND THAT
SORT OF THING AND THAT IS NOT --
IF YOU HAVE IT YOU HAVE 95% OF
THE FIRE STARTING WITH THE
PEOPLE THEY'RE GONNA SHOW OF
THESE MEETINGS.
THAN THAT THE THAT THE EMPHASIS
NEEDS TO BE ON THOSE MEETINGS
AND WHAT IS THE KIND TO IT IT'S
THE FST.
THANK YOU YOU REALLY HIT SOME
SPOTS FOR ME BUT WE'LL LET
MISTER LOPEZ NEXT AND HUSBAND.
ON IN A SECOND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VOTE MADAMS --
CHAIRS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER JARRETT THANK
YOU FOR THE POTENTIAL BEING HERE
COMMON FLIGHT FROM LA TODAY TO
BE HERE WITH YOU GUYS TODAY.
I GIVE YOU SOME IDEA WHAT THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SO DEFENSIBLE SPACE --
BACK THEN CALLED PORSCHE
CLEARANCE IS STARTING SUCH A
DISCOUNT IN NINETEEN FIFTY THE
FIRST DOCUMENT THAT WE GOT.
BACK TO FIFTY FOUR IT WAS
MENTIONED --
HOWEVER THERE WAS A
RECOMMENDATION SUCH A TIME THEY
BEGIN MANDATORIES IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES BASED ON THE
STATE CODES --
FORTY TWO NINETY ONE FORTY TWO
NINETY AND THE LA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT --
SERVICE THAT THE ONLY CORPORATE.
AREAS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY PLUS
FIFTY NINE INCORPORATED CITIES
AT THAT WEEK --
DO THE SAME FIRE PREVENTION
PROJECTS WITH THEM HAMPER PIPER
OF PROTECTION WELL WITH THEM.
UP ENFORCEMENT PART OF THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE HAVE THE KIND OF THE
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
PROGRAM --
WITH THIS IS A JOINT PROGRAM
BETWEEN THE FIRE DEPARTMENT AND
THE AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONERS
OFFICE.
WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT --
INSPECTS THE IMPROVE PROPERTIES
THE GONNA ACOSTA COMMISSION
OFFICE INSPECT THE AYE CHASTENED
BAKER ALLOWANCE TO DOSE IN
IMPROVE PROPERTIES.
SO THAT THE LATTER ARE OF US
LIKE TO POLITICAL NINETY SOME IS --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ART THERE WILL
BE SUFFICIENT WHEN IT TO HAVE A
ALSO INSPECT AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE NEIGHBOR DOLLARS THE THIRTY
TWO BRIDGES THE FIRE HAS A FOUR
DOT NEIGHBOR.
THAT PUT THE HOME SO CLOSE TO
THE PROPERTY LINE.
UP SO WE DID THAT WE LA COUNTY
SPECS ABOUT THIS YEAR WE'RE
GONNA SPEC 510-007-0090.
SEVEN OF OF HOMES.
ARE AND BE ABLE TO COACH A
COMMISSIONER WITH SPECTRUM TO
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND BACON.
ALONSO ADJACENT TO THAT --
AND WE DO THAT ANNUALLY OF WITH
THE COUNTY BECAUSE A DECLARATION
LISTS SO EACH PARCEL IS PROPERTY
OWNER GETS A DECLARATION
CARTOONS --
AND NOTICE AND EARLY FEBRUARY
LET HIM KNOW THAT WILL BE BACK
IN THE MIDDLE LATE SPRING TO DO
AN INSPECTION SAID THERE ONE
SECOND THERE WE GIVE THEM A
DEADLINE WHAT THE DEADLINE IS A
PLACE.
WILL FOLLOW WHEN INSPECTIONS AND
WE HAVE A NEW I DO NOT --
IT'S YES IN TECHNOLOGY WE USE IN
A DECLARE PARTS OF ANALYSIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE TOOK THE
CORRECT PARCELS --
THAT NEEDS TO BE INSPECTED ARE
THERE SOME PARCELS ARE CUT
BECOME INDUSTRIAL HAVE BECOME
COMMERCIAL AND WITH DOING SOME
CHANGES AND THAT.
I WANTED THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE USE AND TO DO THAT IS WORKING
WITH CAL FIRE IN THE NEW
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM THAT
THEY HAVE LUNCH AND THAT'S A WE
DID A TEST LAST YEAR.
WE'RE GOING TO USE THAT THIS
YEAR WE HOPE TO IMPLEMENTED BY
NEXT YEAR.
THERE'S THE THINGS THAT CALPERS
WITH THAT WITHOUT THAT SOFTWARE
WILL ALLOW US TO NOT ONLY
COLLECT INFORMATION ON THE
VEGETATION AROUND HOME BUT A
CONFIRMATION ON THE STRUCTURE
ITSELF ON THE EXISTING
STRUCTURES.
WHAT KIND OF ROOF WHAT KIND OF
FENCE WHAT KIND OF SITE IN THE
HOUSE?
AND THE SAME TIME WE CAN SEE
WHAT KIND OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
AS YOU CAN TO COVER HER FROM THE
OTHER SPEAKERS.
ARE DEFENSIBLE SPACE A
COMPREHENSIVE --
OF MEASURE SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'LL BOTH GET
TOGETHER SO WE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH CAL FIRE TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
FIT FINISH IT UP THIS YEAR ON
AND KEEP WORKING ON NEXT YEAR TO
WORK WITH THEM. TO HAVE THAT
VEGETATION AND STRUCTURE OF
COURSE --
DATA.
IT STARTED BUILDING IT UP OF THE
SURF TWO REASONS ONE IS TO HELP.
HELP US HELD THE PROPERTY OWNER
TO MAKE A HOME SAFER BUT IN CASE
SOMETHING HAPPENS ALSO WE CUPS
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED OR WHAT IT
WAS THERE BEFORE THE FIRE CAME.
ON TO SOMETHING DID BURN WHY
COULD HAVE BEEN THE REASON THAT
APART BUT IT DIDN'T BURN WHY DID
THEIR NUMBER SO WE GOT TO STUDY
THE THE THE HEALTHY.
AND THE ON HEALTH --
BUT I THINK THAT WE DO --
AND INSPECTION WORLD BUT IS NOT
REALLY SPECTRUM IS A COOPERATIVE
PROGRAM THAT WOULD DO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
WE CALLED I AM --
POLICE THEMSELVES AND WE GO OUT
THERE INVEST INSPECT UP --
POLLS AND LINES WITH THE PERSON
WAS GOING TO BE DONE THE WORK OF
WE KEEP TRACK OF THAT AND THEN
WE FOLLOW UP AGAIN IS NOT AN
INSPECTION TO CYCLE OPERATION.
BUT THEN WE TRIED WE ASSIST.
US IN CALIFORNIA EDISON TO THE
WORK AND I THINK THAT IT HELP
ANSWER THIS BACHELORS OPENS A
LOT OF THE WORKS.
ARE AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE A BIG
EUCALYPTUS THREE THAT IS RIGHT
NEXT TO A LINE.
AND THEN IS TO BE GONE WE CAN
WORK WITH EDISON'S TO THE
PROPERTY OWNER WANTS HAD GONE.
AN EDISON.
IS JUST DOING ALL THAT MAIN AS
WE ASSESS ON THAT COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE TWO SO THAT.
OUR SELECTION AND IF IT'S
SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE PLANTED
IN THERE WE CAN ASSESS THE
PROPERTY OWNER WHAT TO PLANT
THAT IS NOT GOING TO AFFECT THE
POWER LINES SO THAT'S ONE OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE GOT.
AND I THINK THAT WE KIND OF IN
THE COUNT IS WHAT WE CALL THE
FUEL MODIFICATION BLUNDER VIEW.
SO YOU HAVE A NEW CONSTRUCTION
FOR A TO REMODEL THERE'S MORE
THAN 50% OF THE SQUARE FOOTAGE
OF THE HOME.
YOU SUBMIT YOUR A LANDSCAPER
PLANS TO US AND WE ARE REVIEWING.
IS A CONDITION FOR A A OCCUPANCY
AND WE'D NOT ONLY WORK WITH THE
PROPERTY OWNER WITH THE PROPER
SPACE IN --
AT ELATED ON THAT TASTIC
ADDITION TO OUR PLAN.
UP BUT IS THIS REVIEW IN THE
LANDSCAPE IN AND I'M.
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROPERTY
OWNERS.
ARE UNDERSTAND WHAT.
PROPER SPACING AND PROPER --
PLAN SELECTION WILL DO WE DO NOT
HAVE A FIRE FOR SYSTEM PLAN
LISTS --
BECAUSE IS WE'VE REALLY.
PUT ATTENTION ON MAINTENANCE.
WHAT THE SPACE AND ON THE
LOCATION OF THE PLANET'S
RELATIONSHIP TO THE HOME AND NOT
ONLY THE HOME ITSELF OF THE HOME
FISHERIES THEMSELVES WINDOWS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WITH THE?
CAUSE OF FIRES GOING TO FIND A
LIST PATH OF RESISTANCE OR START
WHAT -- WHAT
CAN THEY WENT TO THE CALL AND SO
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD WITH
THEM ONCE THEY GET ALL THAT DONE
WITH SUSPECT THEM EVERY YEAR
THEY BECOME PART OF THIS FIFTH
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION?
I MAKE SURE THAT THE LANDSCAPING
IS NOT MODIFIED IT IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS --
ANYONE IN ADDITION TO DOING THIS
WORK WITH THEM --
ACOSTA BE THE EDUCATION SO WE
CAUGHT SEVERAL PROBLEMS THAT
WOULD DO A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
EDUCATION --
SAFETY IS A CONTACT SPORT SO YOU
HAVE TO GO AND SPEND TIME WITH A
A WOULD YOU FIRES THE COUNCIL'S --
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT WE
WORKING REAL HARD RIGHT NOW IS
THAT IS THAT.
OF UP DEFENSIBLE SPACES THAT
RELATES TO THE DOSE ORNAMENTAL
PLANTS THAT WE TEND NOT TO OVER
THAT WE WE CANNOT MAKE THE STATE
FREEWAYS SAFER.
ACTUALLY RECEIVED IN THIS BILL
LIMITS SUCH ARE GOING UP BUT WE
CAN MAKE THE CAR SICK FOR SO WE
CAN TAKE THAT CONSERVE ON BRING
IT TO THE HOMES HIMSELF SIDE YOU
HER SOME SOME PREVIOUS.
VENDOR SO WE WORK REALLY HARD
AND GETTING THAT DONE WE COME UP
ON MY SCHOOL MEET YOU FIRE
INSPECTOR BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE SAID YOU SENT ME THIS
NOTICE EVERY YEAR.
BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT KNOW
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL ME HERE HOW
TO SUPPORT TO LOOK AT MY
PROPERTY NOTHING DOES WHAT THEY
SAY IS THAT.
SO WE PUT AN EXAMPLE FOR REAL SO
BRING THE LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS SO
IS THERE IS A UNIFIED.
UNDERSTANDING OR WHAT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE LOOK LIKE WHICH YOU KNOW
WE WE HAVE A PRESENTATION ALSO
CALLED THE GOOD THE BAD AND THE
UGLY.
AND NOW WE WHICH I'M WHAT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT WE ALSO DO
HOME IGNITION TRAINING --
THEY'VE CALIFORNIA FAR TO CANCEL
BEEN REALLY GENEROUS SO WE CUT
DOWN ABOUT TWENTY A HOMING
MISSION TRAINING FOR THE
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT'S FOR IN
WHICH THEY LEARN WHAT ARE THE
CHARACTERISTICS THAT --
OR DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
REDUCE THE FIRE HAS A TO THE
CLUB IN THOSE FIRST A HUNDRED
FEET.
STARTING WITH THE HOME ITSELF
AND AND WORK ON THE WAY OUT.
AND THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
THING TO DO AND WE ALSO RECOVERY
VICE ALREADY SICKLE AND VIDEOS
AND I WILL SEND A COPY TO MISTER
JARRETT WHEN I'LL COME.
TO AND THEY WOULD THINK THAT YOU
US GOT YOUR MITCHELL LITERALLY
MAY I IS THAT WHERE THE SOMEBODY
FIND INFORMATION OF HOW TO BE
MORE FAR SAFE.
AND A GREAT WAY TO DO DIS BY
CREATING A COMMUNITY WHILE FIVE
PROTECTION PLAN THE CAMARO ABOUT
FIVE BRITISH AND ESPECIALLY
CUTTING A DEAL TO FIRE UP --
HOMING MISSION.
THE QUALITY OF THE CALL MANY
WELFARE PROTECTION PLAN IS TO
BRING ALL THAT ARE COVERED IN A
DOCUMENT.
THAT IS COMMUNITY BASED ON IS
AVAILABLE FOR THEM YOU WANNA
CHANGE YOUR WINDOWS YOU GO TO
THE FIRES.
SAID THAT REPEAT TO SEE WHAT --
WHAT THE BEST WINDOWS DEFENSE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IS A GREAT
DOCUMENT FOR YOU DID IT AT A ONE
MORE THING THAT WE'RE DOING THAT
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO DO IS THAT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS --
THE THE THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
RFR PREVENTION FUND WOULD HAVE
DONE QUITE A BIT OF WORK IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WITH THEM.
IN ADDITIONAL WHAT THE FIRE
SECONDS OF CAN DO THEMSELVES THE
CCC CAN HELP US IN THIS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE WAR.
A WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORK
WITH THEM WITH THE OP CALM AND
GRANTS PROGRAM THEY CáC
CALIFORNIA CLIMB AND INVESTMENT
FIVE PREVENTION --
GRANT PROGRAM ALSO WORKING WITH
THEM BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE TO US
ABOUT THE WAY WE JUST HIRE A
CORE MEMBER --
AT JOE'S IN NOVEMBER TO START
WORKING WITH US AND JUST A GREAT
SOURCE NOT ONLY THE WORK BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT COME OUT OF THAT
PROGRAM I JUST FANTASTIC.
AND REPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS --
SURE PROBABLY LORD AS AS WELL.
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
ABOUT EDUCATION EDUCATION
EDUCATION --
IT'S EASY TO SAY YOU DON'T KNOW
BUT IF YOU HAVE THE INFORMATION
OUT THERE AND OBVIOUSLY MEANT
ALL OF YOU WERE DOING THAT I'M
TRYING TO BUT THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO KNOW.
MY REAL COMMUNITIES --
AS MANY TIMES AS A FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR UTILITIES OR
WHATEVER TRIES TO GO TO THEIR
LAND.
DOES THE PRIVATE PROPERTY AND
THEN THAT THEY MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO GO OUT
THERE AND I THINK.
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE RESULTS
OF THAT FROM SOME OF THE FIRES.
AND SO THE CHALLENGES IS THAT
HOW DO WE GET THOSE PEOPLE TO
GET ON BOARD THE SOME AT LEAST
SOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND TO
REALIZE THAT THEY'RE HARMING NOT
ONLY.
THEMSELVES BUT THEY'RE HARMING.
OTHERS ALONG THE WAY SO --
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A TOUGH ONE
BERMAN AS WE KNOW IN --
OF THE CAMPFIRE WE WERE MISSING
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
IT'S COULD THOUGHT OF THAT MANY
OF THOSE PEOPLE DIDN'T WANT TO
BE FOUND THEY LIVED UP IN THE
HILLS AND YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS
WHAT'S HAPPENED UP THERE BUT THE
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
HIS RURAL AREAS I MEAN I THINK
YOU'RE DOING A REALLY GOOD JOB
ANYMORE CUT CONCENTRATED URBAN
AREAS.
BUT I THINK THIS MISTER THOMPSON
KNOWS IS IT SOME UP IN OUR AREAS
UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO GET THAT
EDUCATION.
AND TO GET PEOPLE TO GET
TOGETHER TO ACTUALLY HAVE THESE
REALLY GOOD CONVERSATIONS OF
PUTTING THESE GROUPS TOGETHER SO --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SOME
IDEAS THAT I PICKED UP HERE
TODAY --
ALSO IS THAT I'M SURE YOU DO
THIS BUT I'M HOPING THIS IS DONE
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES --
WE CAME UP WITH THE FIRES THAT
WE IT HAD THE IN OUR AREA WAS
THAT WE HAD MANY PEOPLE THAT
DIDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
AND WE HAD A HARD TIME MAKING
SURE IN IT WASN'T INTENTIONAL
READ ALTHOUGH WE COMMUNICATE IN
SPANISH BUT THERE IS MANY OTHER
LANGUAGES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
SO THAT --
AND DO YOU DO THAT CURRENTLY OR
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE'S LEFT BEHIND ON SOME OF
THESE EDUCATION TOOLS AND IF YOU
ANSWER THAT IN A SECOND --
MAYES ABOUT RESPONSIBILITY.
THERE'S A HOME OWNER OR PROPERTY
OWNER THE LACK OF RUNS
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S EASY TO
POINT FINGERS AND AS YOU SAID IS
90% OR 95% OF THE FIRES ARE DONE
BY THE PUBLIC --
EDUCATING PEOPLE TO EVEN LEARN
HOW TO WALK INTO THE WALKING
TRAILS.
YOU MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
TAKING EXTRA THINGS ALONG THE
WAY I'VE SEEN IT WITNESS IT WENT
TOO MANY TIMES THEY'LL SAY NO DO
KNOW DOGS.
AND WHAT HAPPENS EVERYONE'S GOT
A DOG GOING ON THE WORKING TO
THERE'S A REASON THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN RIGHT.
AND SO --
WE'RE NOT PROTECTING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES AS WELL AS WHEN PEOPLE
ARE NOT BEING --
RESPONSIBLE AND HONOR OUR OPEN
SPACE AND SO I'VE HAD THE LAST
THING I'D EVER WANT TO DO DURING.
IS TO CLOSE DOWN OPEN SPACE
DURING FIRE SEASON FUHRMAN
FOLLOW THE RULES WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT SO I
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT THAT --
DOES IT IT'S IT IF YOU WERE TO
ASK ME MY BATTALION CHIEF WHAT
WERE THE TOP THREE THINGS THAT
THEY SAW DURING THE TUBS FIRE.
THAT WERE THE CAUSATION FOR A
LOT OF STRUCTURE FIRES --
DAVID SAY.
WOOD CHIPS AROUND THE PERIMETER
OF THE HOME.
HOME COMPUTER MARKET SOME PEOPLE
CAUGHT THAT.
AND THEN WOOD DECKS WITHOUT ANY
SKIRTING EARNING PROTECTION OR
ANYTHING AND THEN WE HOPE MORE
KIND GRASS UNDERNEATH THE THE
TEXAS OF WHAT.
WE WE DID A INSPECTION OF COPY
PARK.
AS FIRE STATION RIGHT AFTER THE
FIRES ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
SAW WAS THAT PEOPLE PARKED THERE --
PLASTIC.
RECYCLE AND TRASH BINS RIGHT UP
AGAINST THE HOUSE UNDERNEATH THE
EAVES UNDERNEATH THE OVERHANG
AND SO WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT EMBERS YOU HAVE TO START
SAME OKAY WHEN THE EMBERS GET
THERE.
WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM?
YOU KNOW GOING IN THE ATTIC
LANDING ON THE WOOD CHIPS IN IN
A LOT OF CASES THEY PLAN ON
THESE PLASTIC BINS IN THOSE
PLASTIC BINS.
JUST GO OFF LIKE A ROMAN CANDLE
UP THE SIDE OF THE WALL ENTER
THE EAVES OF THE HOUSE AND THEN
YOU'RE OFF TO THE RACES AND SO.
I HAVE FOUND THROUGH OUR FSC
THAT.
THAT HAVING --
SOME VERY SIMPLE. TO DUES ACROSS
THIS PRODUCT OFF THE LIST.
PEOPLE ARE VERY RECEPTIVE THEY
JUST FEEL COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED
WHEN THEY SAY THEY GET ALL THIS
INFORMATION AT ONCE AND THAT'S
NOT WITHIN THE VERNACULAR THEY
UNDERSTAND OR USED.
TO HERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO DO IT.
OR THEY WANT TO WRITE A CHECK
AND HAVE SOME DO IT FOR THEM.
AND IF 8095% OF THE FIRES A
START BY HOMEOWNERS IN IN OUR
CASE. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF GRANT MONEY COMING IN
HAS TO BE USED FOR COUNTY ROADS
WE CAN'T USE IT FOR PRIVATE
PROPERTIES.
THERE'S A PROBLEM THERE YEAH WE
CAN TAKE CARE THE EGRESS WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF THE ZONES ON YOUR
SIDE OF THE ROAD BUT WE CAN'T
GET INTO PEOPLE'S PROPERTY WITH
THAT MONEY AND THAT'S WHERE A
LOT OF THESE PROBLEMS OCCUR.
BUT I A CHAIR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND SO
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
GONNA BE COMING UP IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS BECAUSE WE'RE
REALLY WORKING AT HOUSING AND
REZONING IN.
HOW YOU HOW YOU FACE SO SING SO
WE HAVE A LOT?
BETTER.
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH SOON
SO -- THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I HAD TO
SHOW -- IN
NOVEMBER FOR OUR STATE
ASSOCIATION I GET SO MANY CALLS
FROM REPORTERS BACCHAE SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HOW COME IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN
SAN DIEGO?
AND DURING THAT FOUR DAY
CONFERENCE WE HAD THREE FIRES
BREAKOUT.
BUT I I'VE FRANKLY JUST TOLD HIM
I SAID YOU KNOW IN THEIR DEFENSE.
WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH THIS
FOR A LOT LONGER.
AND WE HAD TO GET BUSY AND WE
HAD TO GET ORGANIZED AND WE HAD
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND WE
DID -- ITO
IT'S IT'S TERRIBLE TO SEE PEOPLE
DYING BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO EVACUATE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO GO THEY DON'T KNOW
WEARS A SAFE PLACE TO SHELTER --
THE ROADS ARE CLEARED THEY'RE
JUST LOST AND IT'S IT'S A MATTER
IT IS THAT OUT REACH IT IS THAT
AT EDUCATION.
AND I BELIEVE.
YOU SAID IT EARLIER IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF OF FIVE IF IT'S WHEN
BUT IT'S I THINK IT'S GONE
BEYOND THAT AT THIS POINT
CALIFORNIA THEY USED TO SAY WE
LIVE WITH EARTHQUAKES.
EARTHQUAKES AREN'T THE PROBLEM
IT'S WILD FIRE.
AND SO.
HAVING EDUCATION.
TELLING PEOPLE LOOK YOU HAVE TO
GET BUSY HONEST IT IT'S THE ONLY
WAY YOU'RE GONNA SURVIVE YOUR
PROPERTIES GOING TO SURVIVE AND
YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP YOUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THE BACK COUNTRY DON'T
LIKE WHEN AN AGENCY COMES IN AND
SAYS HERE.
A MANY GIVE YOU A TICKET IF YOU
DON'T DO THIS THEIR BACK THERE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
REGULATED BUT YOU'VE GOT THAT
PERFECT VEHICLE WITH THE FIRE
SAFE COUNCIL OR IN OUR CD THAT
RELATIONSHIP. TO GO IN AND BE
THAT INTERFACE BETWEEN THE
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER.
AND THE AGENCY AND IT IS JUST
WORKED VERY VERY SUCCESSFULLY.
AND WE'RE ALWAYS WE'VE HELPED
OTHER DEVELOPED FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS MENDOCINO TA WHOLE --
ANYONE WHO WANTS ONE BUT THERE
CRUCIAL AND ONCE YOU.
START THAT STRUCTURE TO THEN YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO APPLY FOR
THOSE GRANTS.
THAT WILL FIND YOUR PROJECTS AND
GRANTS CLEARING HOUSE CALIFORNIA
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL --
THERE'S STAPLE WE'VE WORKED WITH
THEM FOR YEARS R. C. W. PPV
PLANETS ON THEIR WEBSITE I MEAN.
THERE ARE WAYS TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT YOU TO KNOW IT
DIDN'T KNOW IT DIDN'T THAT WE
STARTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE THING YOU JUST
MENTIONED AND I JUST WANT TO
THROW IT OUT THERE IS THAT.
FIRE --
FORCED BUYERS AND IN URBAN AREAS
I THINK WE SHOULD NOT FORGET.
I THINK WE'RE EASILY FORGETTING
IS THAT THERE COULD BE AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THERE WILL BE
FIRES YEAH.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO PUT THAT
IN OUR PLANS AS WELL IS AND
THAT'S JUST NOT A A RURAL AREA
OR OR OPEN SPACE AREA BUT IN OUR
HEART OF OUR MAJOR CITIES.
IS THAT WITH DURING IT ERIS
QUAKE THE FIRES ARE GOING TO BE
THE THING TO GET PEOPLETHE MOST.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AND WE'RE
NOT HAVING IT AT LEAST --
WE DO RIGHT WHEN THE EARTHQUAKES
HAPPEN THEN WE HAVE FOR A COUPLE
MONTHS AND THEN GOES AWAY SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE TO PUT THAT IN
OUR PLANTS AS WELL.
MAY I ANSWER YOUR QUESTION SO OF
FIRE PREVENTION CAN BE.
A AND YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT
FIVE PREVENTION IS TO BE
DISSECTED AND PROVIDE THE
CORRECT INFORMATION FOR CIVIL
CALL FIRE PROVIDE A VERY GOOD
DATA.
OF ACE OF WHAT THE REAL A FISA A
CONDITION START.
ARE -- A
BECAUSE WE KEEP LEHMAN
CIGARETTES AND CIGARETTES THE
OUT OF THE WINDOW IS NOT THE ONE
NUMBER --
ONE OF FIRE OF PREVENTION WORK
IS YOU ONE OF THE BIG ONES --
ACTIVITIES HAPPENED DURING
CAPTAINCY SENATE THINGS LAST
ANOTHER ONE SO GET IN THE RIGHT
SOURCE BUT ARE NOT ONLY IF OUR
PROVINCIAL SUFFERS SILVER LAKE
TO FIGHT MISSION.
BUT ALSO FIRE PROPAGATION SO YOU
WERE SPEAKING ABOUT WE JUST HAD
A FIRE YOU GOT A JOB DOES THE
FIRST PREVENTION THING IT IS BUT
NOW THAT THE FIRE STARTED.
NOW YOU KIND OF A BOYCOTT THE
FIRES GOING TO PROVOKE A TO A
COMMUNITY A YOU MADE SOME
RECEIVE INFORMATION.
THAT WE USE THE OF READY SET
CALLED THE RIGHT A PART OF THE
PREPARATION.
AND AND WHAT HAPPENED AND ALL
THE WAY TILL YOU CUT THE
EVACUATE BECAUSE YOU TRIED TO
DEAL WITH ALL AT THE SAME TIME
IS GOING TO BE JUST TOO MUCH
INFORMATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU OFFER YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
REALLY GREAT TO KIND OF DRILL
DOWN INTO THE MORE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH THIS PANEL SO THANK YOU I
MEAN I ASKED TO FLOW BECAUSE A
SIMILAR QUESTION I'VE BEEN
ASKING WHICH IS WHETHER LA
COUNTY.
HAS ANY ASSISTANCE FOR LOW
INCOME ELDERLY HOMEOWNERS ON OUR
PROPERTY OWNERS --
WITH ANY OF THE FIRERESILIENCE
YOUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE WORK.
BUT THE BEST PLACE THAT NEVER
THINK THAT WE CAN DO IS HELP AND
GET ORGANIZED AS A FIRES CUTS.
ON THE ONE AT THE FIRST THING WE
DO IF WE HAVE A COMMAND IS
CONCERNED --
WE GO OUT THERE MEET WITH THEM
AND SEE IF THEY CAN GET
ORGANIZED A FIVE SECOND SO HE'S
VERY LITTLE AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THEM BUT IT CAN GET ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT BEHIND WHEN YOU SAY THEM
WHO WHO IS THEM.
ERIC A COMMUNITY --
IT'S A COMMON ENOUGH THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT HILLS A
COMMUNITY IN A WAY TO HEAR --
IT DID.
EIGHT ARE CONCERNED OF FIRE AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BECOME A FIVE
SECONDS. TO REASONS ONE IS NOT
ALL THAT THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO
BE SELF SUFFICIENT.
UP OFFERS THE COUNCIL ALLOWS THE
THE ARE ALLOW US.
TO PASS THAT KNOWLEDGE AND
ENCOURAGE THE COMMUNITY
KNOWLEDGE AS A RELEASED A FIRE
AT A WILDFIRE YOU COULD SEE TWO
GREAT EXAMPLES RIGHT HERE.
THE OTHER ONE IS ALSO ALLOWS THE
COMMUNITY TO APPLY FOR GRANTS
AND LASTLY A TO AVOID CONFLICT
OF OR WHAT WE CALL --
IN A WE CAN I JUST HELP UP --
LIKE THE RECITAL WAS SAYING
YOU'RE GONNA GO A TO A PRIVATE
PROPERTY INTO THEIR WORK --
BUT WE CAN DO THAT WHAT THE CALM
THAT.
HELPS THE COMMUNITY.
AND YOU WORK WITH --
CITIES ASWELL INDEPENDENT
CITIES OR CITY SORT OF THEIR OWN
FIRE DEPARTMENTS YES THE WAY WE
CAUGHT IN A VERY CLOSELY.
OF VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CITY'S
OPPOSITE ENOUGH OF BURBANK --
UNTIL CITIES THAT ARE ADJACENT
TO US WE WORK VERY CLOSELY OF
BEVERLY HILLS.
AND OF ALL OF YOU APPLIED FOR
CAL FIRE GRANTS AND IF YOU HAVE
A HOUSE THAT PROCESS TO FIND AT
THAT PROCESSES.
IS OUR AS SMOOTH APPLIED FOR
QUITE A FEW.
AND I REALIZED AFTER.
NOT GETTING THE FIRST TWO THAT I
NEED TO HAVE A A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH OUR CAL FIRE
FORSTER.
SO BASICALLY I SAID WHAT IS A
PRIORITY AREA.
FOR CAL FIRE IT WAS A SUNRISE
FEEL BREAK WHICH IS A REAL
CRITICAL FRUIT SHE'LL BREAK FOR
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
SO CALIFORNIA TO WORK ON THE
FIELD BREAK BUT THEY DON'T HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO GET INTO THE
PROPERTY THE PRIVATE PROPERTY
THAT A BUT SAID.
SO WE DIRECTED THOSE GRANT FUNDS
TOWARDS THAT AND IT WAS AMAZING
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A TWO HUNDRED
WAIT LIST IN WE'VE JUST GOT SOME
GRANTS WILL COME AND THEN I'LL
HAVE IS CHIPPING AWAY WITH THAT.
BUT WE NEVER ADVERTISE FOR
CHIPPING PROGRAMS.
WE ADVERTISE WE ONLY HAD A 30%
RESPONSE FOR THAT COMMUNITY
AFTER WE STARTED WORK WE SEND
OUT ANOTHER AND WE HAD AN 85%.
CHANCE AND WITHIN FOUR MONTHS WE
HAD EXPENDED THE FUNDS.
AND PEOPLE WERE CALLING TO SEE
IF WE HAD MORE.
SO.
THE THE PROCESS ISN'T THAT
DIFFICULT BUT I THINK YOUR BEST
CHANCES OF SUCCESS ARE TO WORK
WITH THEM.
AND FIND PROJECTS THAT YOU CAN
DO AS AND WE DON'T.
A FIRE SAFE COUNCIL OR NURSERY
DE THAT WILL HELP THEM MEET
THEIR FIRE PLAN GOALS
[inaudible]
GREAT --
CHIEF --
WHAT WOULD YOU THINK THERE'S A
BENEFIT TO INSPECTING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE EVERY YEAR SUPPOSED EVERY
THREE YEARS OR DO YOU THINK IT?
DOESN'T MAKE AS MUCH MAKE THAT
MUCH DIFFERENCE.
OTHER SEVEN EFFORT TO CASSETTE
OXIDE ARE OF INTEREST IS A
CONTACT SPORT AND THAT DAYLIGHT
TO US NOT COMMON AND WHAT NOT
EVERYBODY.
BUT A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE LIKE TO
US TO COME EVERY YEAR AND PAY A
VISIT AND SEE HOW THEY'RE DOING.
AND THEY GET A CHANCE TO YOU
KNOW TALK ABOUT THE NEIGHBOR
WHAT THE NEIGHBORS TO AND ALL
THAT -- AND
ANY KEEP THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM --
DEPTHFIRE PREVENTION OF THE
PHYSICAL SPACES ALL YEAR ROUND
PROCESS SO WE TRIED TO WORK WITH
THEM.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR --
AT INCIRLIK CALIFORNIA IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT AND I
CALIFORNIA CHOPPER ALL THE
GRASSES ARE VERY CLOSE TO EACH
OTHER SO WE CAN.
WE CUT TO BE REALLY VIGILANT TO
WILL HOW THEY INTERACT SO WE TRY
TO KEEP THAT SEPARATION.
WITHIN.
THE LEGISLATION OF ROUND THE
HOMES BUT ALSO THE VEGETATION
WITHIN THAT SPACE THOUGHT
ORNAMENTAL BUDGET TATIAN.
THE TENTH TO GET AWAY A BOOK ON
BILLY I CAN GROW CAN GROW REALLY
FAST IN ONE YEAR.
AND BECOME A REAL PROBLEM FOR US
SO IT'S GOOD TO REMIND HIM YEAR.
IS SIX IS A LOT OF WORK FIND OUT
WHAT IT WAS WHAT JUST LIKE TO
ADD THAT I THINK.
THERE SHOULD BE MORE MONEY.
I THINK THAT THAT.
WE SHOULD NOT BE TALKING ABOUT
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS FOR PREVENTION WHEN
WE'RE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO MOP UP.
AND SO I THINK THERE THERE IS AN
IMPASSE TO BE AN EXPERT IN THIS
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM BUT I I
I I THINK YOU KNOW IF YOU KNOW
HOW TO DO IT.
AND YOU HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITH IT.
THEN I THINK YOU CAN MANAGE
GETTING THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
GETTING GRANTS AND SO FORTH.
BUT I I THINK GIVE THEM WHAT THE
GRANTS CAN DO AND HOW IT
LEVERAGES.
THE THE THE THE THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SO THAT ALL THAT IS
TAKEN OFF THE BACKS OF CAL FIRE
TO THEIR NOT HAVING TO DO ALL
THAT --
INSPECTION AND SO FORTH I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE EMPHASIS
ON IT.
THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHERS SAY WELL.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF
THE PANELISTS AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS WHO JOINED US TODAY --
THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL HEARINGS
ABOUT WILDFIRES AND THEY'LL BE
LOTS MORE BUT I FIND THAT EVERY
TIME WE HAVE A DIFFERENT PANEL
COME UP WE'RE WE WE HAVE NEW AN
EXTREMELY VALUABLE INFORMATION --
AND WE'RE STARTING TO I MEAN I
FEEL PERSONALLY LIKE I'M
STARTING TO PUT PIECES OF A
PUZZLE TOGETHER.
SO THIS IS BEEN INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE TO ME SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR TIME WITH
US AND YOUR EXPERTISE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED BUT FOR HAVING US.
WELL I'M SORRY. TO ANYBODY --
FOR PUBLIC PUMP COMMENT IF IF SO
PLEASE COME IN LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU CAN --
STATE YOUR NAMES PLEASE.
MY ON THERE WE GO HI MY NAME'S
TRACY CATTLEMEN ON THE NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIRES A COUNCIL AND
RECENTLY MOVED TO WOODLAND AS A
ONE WEEK SO.
HAPPY TO BE IN YOUR DISTRICT --
WANTED TO ECHO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HEARD HERE TODAY
ONE IS THAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO
ORDER FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AROUND
THE STATE.
AND ALMOST ANOTHER TWO UNDER
FIRE WAS COMMUNITIES AND THEY
REALLY ARE FRONTLINE FOLKS THERE
THE FOLKS ON THE GROUND WHO KNOW
WHERE THEY LIVE WHO CARE ABOUT
THEIR NEIGHBORS.
AND ARE OUT THERE LOOKING AT
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO MAKE THEIR
COMMUNITIES MORE SAY SO I THINK.
IT IT'S A I DON'T WANNA TALK
TALK ABOUT FIRST ACCOUNTS IS A
RESOURCE BUT REALLY IT IS A
RESOURCE THAT WE HAVE STATEWIDE
IN TERMS OF A WAY TO GET
RESOURCES TO THE GROUND AND TO
GET PRAGUE. TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS ON THE GROUND SOME SAY
IT'S ALREADY IN PLACE WE DON'T
HAVE TO REBUILD THAT --
SOME YOU TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
DOING HOME ASSESSMENTS ASSISTING
WITH ELDERLY LOW INCOME FOLKS.
CLOSER THAT'S WHERE THAT HAPPENS
A LOT OF FIRES ARE COUNCILS WILL
GET FUNDING OFTEN THROUGH OUR
GRANT CLEARING HOUSE OR TO CAL
FIRE. TO BE CREATING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE FOR LOW INCOME ELDERLY
DISABLED NEIGHBORS DOING
SHIPPING PROGRAMS ON THOSE
PROPERTIES SO THOSE ARE CRUCIAL
IN TERMS OF TAKING CARE THEIR
NEIGHBORS AND KNOWING WHERE
THOSE NEIGHBORS ARE WHEN IT
COMES TIME FOR EVACUATION --
ALSO LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS DO
THAT HERE'S THEIR ALSO FRONT
LINE OUT THERE ON I JUST MOVED
FROM HUMBLE COUNTY OF FORTY TWO
DIFFERENT FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
OF AGING WORKFORCE IN THE
VOLUNTEER FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND
THEY'RE ALSO DOING THOSE HOME
ASSESSMENTS --
BUT DEFINITELY A RESOURCE IN AN
AREA THAT NEEDS SOME ATTENTION --
MMHM.
MY SENSE IS THAT IF WE COULD GET
SOME FUNDING TO EVERY COUNTY FOR
EACH COUNTY FIRE SAY COUNCIL
THAT THEN COULD GET DOWN TO THE
GROUND TO LOCAL PHARMACY
COUNCILS THE MULTIPLIER EFFECT
WOULD BE PRETTY PHENOMENAL.
AND THAT WHAT YOU HEARD HERE WAS
THAT THERE ARE THERE'S FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS WERE SPECIALLY FOR
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS.
LOT OF MONEY COMING DOWN TO THE
GROUND THERE'S NOT FUNDING TO
PAY THAT COORDINATOR.
AND SO THERE'S NOT SOMEBODY WHO
CAN FACILITATE ALL THAT TO WORK
WITH ALL THE VOLUNTEERS TO BE
WRITING THE GRANTS TO BE DOING
THE PERMITTING ALL THAT KIND OF
THING.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED BE LOOK
AT HOW CAN WE GET APPROXIMATE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE AND WE
FIGURED IT'S AROUND. TWELVE
MILLION KATE I THINK WE FIGURED
OR DOING SOME.
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE
CALCULATIONS --
AND THAT COULD LOOK IT.
THAT COULD COME DOWN THROUGH A
VARIETY WAYS HUMBOLDT COUNTY
ENCOURAGE YOU LOOK AT HUMBOLDT
COUNTY BECAUSE THEY'RE COUNTY
FIRE SAY COUNSEL WAS STARTED.
BY THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
I BELIEVE THIS PART OF THE
GENERAL PAM GENERAL PLAN PROCESS
WE JUST UPDATED THE THIRD
VERSION OF THE HOME MECHANIC
NEED WELFARE PROTECTION PLAN.
AND WAS ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
PAPER THE NOW THROUGH THAT
PROCESS THEIR NEW C. W. PPV
COMMITTEE WELFARE PROTECTION
PLAN.
THEY REALIZE IT --
MAYBE WE HAVE A GENERAL PLAN
ISSUE IN TERMS OF BUILD OUT IN
HIGH RISK AREAS AND NOT HAPPEN
BECAUSE INCREDIBLY COLLABORATIVE
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL.
THAT COUNSEL IS FUNDED AND NOT
FUNDED BUT STAFF THROUGH COUNTY
OF PUBLIC WORKS PERSON WHO'S
BEEN THERE THROUGHOUT AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY'RE
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL.
OTHER COUNTIES LIKE SAN DIEGO
MENACE YOU KNOW NOW SAN MATTEO
ARE DOING IT THROUGH THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
OTHERS ARE PRIVATE ABOUT THESE
YEAH OTHERS A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET THOSE --
FUNDS DOWN TO THE GROUND AT THE
STATE FAIR CITY COUNCIL WERE NOW
LOOKING AT HOW TO BUILD A
RESOURCE CENTER ENSURE THOSE
RESOURCES STATEWIDE. TO CREATE
THAT WEBSITE TO CREATE THE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES BILL THE
CAPACITY SO WERE AROUND I'M NOW
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WOODLAND SO
HAPPY [inaudible]
TO CONNECT BANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
DINNER BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU.
FOR HOLDING THIS AND VERY
IMPORTANT AND VERY PRACTICE
HEARING IT'S NICE TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN A HEARING --
EARLY ON IN THE SESSION RATHER
THAN.
IN THE LAST WEEK OR TWO SO AS WE
HEARD TODAY THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT --
HOMES AND HUMAN LIVES IS TO WORK
FROM THE HOME OUT RATHER THAN
THE WILD LANDS AND WILDFIRES
INEVITABLE MASSIVE.
HUMAN MáS AND PROPERTY LOSS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT IS NOT
INEVITABLE.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF TO SEE
HOW WE CONTRACT --
SOME OF THIS FIRE PREVENTION
MONEY TO GETTING --
HOMES HARD AND AND DO SOME OF
THAT --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WORK FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE RIDLEY ONE
THINKING TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO CAME TO SPEAK AND SO
TO THE HEARING THE THROUGH VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS --
AND THANKS EVERYBODY WHO WHO
PARTICIPATED OUR STAFF WHO DID A
GREAT JOB PUTTING TOGETHER A
REALLY REALLY INFORMATIVE GROUP
OF PANELISTS SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH